foreign
[Music]
hi everyone i'm alison wagenfeld with
google cloud welcome to google cloud
next and thank you to our google
orchestra composed of bay area googlers
we are coming to you live from our
google cloud campus in silicon valley
where i'm here with sundar pichai and
thomas curion we have an incredible
lineup over the next three days with
live keynotes demos and q a with our
leadership in over 140 sessions covering
all our cloud solutions
our customers and partners will share
how they're using google cloud in google
workspace technology to tackle their
greatest challenges and opportunities we
are humbled to support their work and
share their stories
thank you for being here with us
and now please join me in welcoming
google and alphabet ceo sundar pichai
hi everyone welcome to google cloud next
2021
we are happy you're here
of course i'd be happier if he could
actually be here in person
don't get me wrong thomas is great
company
but he still doesn't laugh at my
container jokes
so while many of us are still waiting
for a return to normal
it does feel like we are on our way
the question is will we recognize normal
when we get there
the pandemic has sped up digitization in
all aspects of our lives it's changed
how we visit a doctor
how our kids learn in school
and how we connect with one another
and it's made the future of work our
present
giving us renewed opportunity to
transform our organizations
from our work with customers
thomas and i have learned there are
three things that position us to be most
helpful to businesses
first our cloud platform
it's designed to help enterprises
transform through digitization
built on the deep investments we've made
in technical infrastructure over the
past 23 years
looking at our networking and data
center investments alone
we have the largest network with the
lowest latency of any cloud provider
with our expansions into warsaw delhi
melbourne and toronto this year we now
have 28 regions with plans for 10 more
and it's all connected by 19 subsea
cables
a grace hopper transatlantic cable will
be the first to incorporate novel
optical fiber switching
second our enterprise customers benefit
from our consumer scale and innovation
we have a deep and broad consumer
ecosystem of devices and services
youtube connects a global community of
viewers and creators android nest
assistant and maps are loved by people
around the world
we have the unique ability to connect
consumer ecosystems with enterprise
ecosystems
for example the realistic voices in
language understanding that powers
google assistant
can improve enterprise customer
experiences and increase satisfaction
and the underlying visual technology
that enables google lens to help people
shop
or learn about a new flower in their
garden
can help manufacturers identify defects
third we offer comprehensive security
that helps organizations including ours
protect what matters
security is foundational to everything
we do
we have a long history of building it
into every layer of the computing
environment
we are a pioneer of zero trust computing
and have deep experience running this
model at scale
on its own any one of these pillars
would be helpful to customers
put together they can be transformative
which is the mission of google cloud
we continue to drive innovation through
our products
over the past year we have had more than
1500 product and feature releases
that's about four a day
they're all designed to be helpful
from smart canvas in google workspace
that makes collaboration richer
to new ai powered industry solutions
and bigquery omni for data analytics
across any cloud
we've also made significant partnership
announcements for example we teamed up
with global telecom leaders such as
ericsson
nokia and t-systems to deliver 5g edge
and hosted computing solutions
what i'm most excited about is how our
strengths in cloud
consumer and security
are helping top enterprises
accelerate their transformation
ford chose google as their
transformation partner
because of our strength in consumer and
cloud
together we are innovating in
electrification
connectivity and self-driving
technologies
ford is harnessing google maps to help
drivers navigate
google assistant to help drivers
concentrate
on google play to keep passengers
learning and entertain
l'oreal partnered across google to build
a virtual try on experience
they are harnessing the best ai models
as well as using youtube to build a
community of fans
and google shopping to make it easy to
discover and buy their products
we are humble that so many organizations
continue to put their trust in google
cloud
and we are committed to helping you
solve the biggest challenges you face
i'll be back a little later to talk more
about how we do that
but first i'll turn the stage over to
thomas korean ceo of google cloud to
talk more about our mission
thank you sundar
hello everyone
it's a pleasure to be here on google's
silicon valley campus
today for the moment we all look forward
to all year long
the opportunity to connect with you
our customers partners and developers
and to share all the amazing exciting
stuff we've been working on
a special thank you to all our sponsors
especially our luminary sponsors
accenture otto's maven wave and deloitte
let's first hear from some of our
customers about the amazing ways in
which they have accelerated
transformation with google cloud
[Music]
the pandemic really did accelerate the
digital wave of change by easily three
to five years
[Music]
we transitioned to all virtual care
we're better positioned to accelerate
fast forward to today we have a truly
profound permanent structural
transformation now our team can look at
hundreds of calls in minutes instead of
weeks
our business has really been transformed
with the help of google cloud we have
spikes in demand we can scale four times
in less than five minutes
schroedinger is transforming the way
scientists are developing drugs chemical
space is almost infinite we can do
things we couldn't do before can't i
just track my shipment we think that we
can help solve that for the supply chain
how can we help workers with artificial
intelligence suddenly lots of ideas
become interesting we're very excited to
develop our artificial intelligence and
machine learning access to innovation
the speed of innovation seconds
milliseconds all matter we're rethinking
routine and pioneering simplicity the
partnership with google cloud provides
us with technology that will drive us to
be better
[Music]
now it's not a secret that many of the
biggest and most innovative technology
companies leaders such as spotify
twitter shopify mikado libre sharechat
dapper labs and so many other exciting
startups and tech leaders
choose google cloud to help them build
scale and innovate
still other customers are transforming
using our purpose-built industry
solutions
the home depot for instance use contact
center ai to reduce customer resolution
time by 91 million minutes
procter gamble
creates personalized omni-channel
journeys from over
275 million consumer records
ikea retail use recommendations ai to
increase e-commerce click-through rates
by 30 percent
and increase order value by two percent
fih a foxconn company used visual
inspection to identify defects
ten times more accurately
mr cooper a leading mortgage services
provider
use document ai to process mortgage
documents
400 percent more efficiently
and bank of new york mellon developed a
liquidity solution
that predicts nearly 40 percent
of security settlement failures with 90
percent accuracy
we're helping many businesses drive
durable innovation through long-term
partnerships with google's
transformation cloud
now to help them transform we focus on
five key themes
one
are we the best at understanding and
using data in an industry
two
do we have the industry's leading
technology infrastructure
three are we creating the best hybrid
workplace for our passionate and
talented employees
four
do we know that our data
systems
and users are secure now
and that they will be secure in the
future
and five
are we working together to address the
most important challenges
facing our world today
we help organizations address these
important questions
let's start with the first question are
we the best at understanding and using
data in an industry
we help organizations unify their data
across multiple clouds and silos
combining structured and unstructured
data and making data every employee's
superpower
using data analytics and ai together
schrodinger accelerated clinical drug
discovery by 60 percent
finding new breakthroughs faster
like many states around the united
states the wisconsin department of
workforce development confronted a wave
of new unemployment claims
using google's data cloud they clear
over
750 000 unemployment claims
reducing claim times from weeks to just
days
and dispersing over 2 billion in
unemployment benefits
walmart is transforming the experience
for the approximately 220 million
shoppers
around the globe who visit a walmart
store
club or e-commerce website each week
i'm honored today to welcome suresh
kumar
executive vice president
walmart's global chief technology
officer and chief development officer
hi thomas and hello everyone
i'm excited to be here today to share
about how we at walmart are innovating
on behalf of our customers
our associates and the role that our
partners like you google have played in
our innovation journey
now i came to walmart at a time of
incredible digital transformation and
jointly with my team
created a robust execution plan to
accelerate the transformation across
three areas
building great customer experiences
optimizing our business and modernizing
our platform and our infrastructure
each of these three priorities are
individually important but when you
bring them together
at the scale of a business like walmart
it has a massive impact if you move with
speed
you can completely transform global
operations
and disrupt entire industries some of
our most data intensive or critical
decisioning process
are getting the bigquery treatment
through this not only are we seeing
significant savings that will continue
as we migrate more and more data over we
are also seeing the ability to use the
data in interesting ways
including enabling analytics at scale
and turning data into actionable
insights from a data migration to
bigquery standpoint
97 percent of the tables used for data
vectors have already migrated to the
cloud
and 30 of the big data have been
migrated
with plans to almost double that by the
end of this fiscal year
and the cherry on the top
is that bigquery has allowed us to
integrate with pretty much any data
visualization tool and analytics tool
that's out there
thereby improving our processing time by
23 percent and of course needless to say
a much better user experience
using bigquery has had a direct impact
on our business
an excellent example is our ability to
close our financial books in three days
instead of five days
and that's a pretty big deal
leveraging our cloud
has enabled us to unleash the potential
of ai across our entire business
this goes from predicting demand to
managing in-stock levels to optimizing
supply chain to freeing up time for our
associates to serve our customers
as one example express delivery which is
our two hour delivery service which we
launched last year
actively uses ai behind the scenes as
the customer is creating that order
multiple algorithms
work in unison
to optimize the delivery route
and determine if the customer is
eligible for express delivery we are
building our own ai and ml capabilities
to power multiple areas of our business
including classification natural
language processing forecasting
regression computer vision predictions
process automations and a whole lot more
so to wrap up
i'm really excited about the opportunity
walmart has to drive innovation and to
further disrupt the retail industry
i hope
you will agree that our work together
is making a huge difference
for our customers and our associates
thank you for having me
thank you suresh
you know tens of thousands of incredible
organizations like walmart
choose google's data cloud for four
reasons
first google's data cloud is the most
complete and unified data and ai
platform
to help you manage every stage of the
data life cycle
from running operational transactions to
developing analytical applications
we help customers unify data lakes and
warehouses as data lake houses
to reduce complexity
and to combine structured and
unstructured data built in data science
and ai with support for mapreduce spark
and presto enables continuous learning
and experimentation
and we support real-time streaming that
natively uses open source standards like
beam and flink
google's data cloud is also unmatched
for speed
scale
security and reliability
bigquery one of the most successful and
beloved data warehouse solutions with
its unique serverless approach
during a typical week
helps more than 3000 different
organizations
analyze more than 200 petabytes of data
and thousands of customers use data proc
to run spark and hadoop clusters easily
spanner a fully managed relational
database with unlimited scale
and multi-zone and multi-region
consistency
serves more than 1
billion requests per second
and provides a 5 9 sla
google data cloud's vertex ai
the ai pioneered at google research and
deep mind so that every data scientist
and ml engineer
can now build deploy and scale ai models
faster
and with 80 percent less code
using ai
the same way google does
for instance ge appliances an appliance
manufacturing leader for more than a
century
is using google cloud including ai the
edge to build innovative digital
products
with over-the-air updates
finally
google's data cloud is more open
standards based
you can choose from postgres mysql
redis mongodb
or migrate from oracle or sql server
and we have strategic partners
with leading data driven applications
for instance
c3ai has made its entire lineup of
ai-based applications available on
google cloud
our customers can analyze
govern and visualize data from many
databases and storage system
on google
or other clouds
including all of google's databases
google sheets
and bigquery
using looker
our premiere bi and embedded analytics
solution
you know today
we're thrilled and excited to announce
that we'll be integrating tableau
a leader in data visualization with
looker
google sheets and bigquery
tableau customers will soon be able to
use looker's semantic model
enabling new levels of data governance
and access to data
let's take a look at this alex over to
you
thank you thomas in this demo we're
going to show you how you can seamlessly
use looker and tableau together to
answer your critical business questions
let's say i work at an e-commerce
company in our looker model provides a
consistent view across the organization
for our most important business metrics
here for example you can see the
definition for gross margin
our looker dashboard is based on that
same semantic model since it provides
trusted insights at a glance i can
immediately see that sales are up
however did i miss anything let's find
out
say i'm more comfortable working in
spreadsheets i can now take advantage of
the new integration between looker and
google sheets
with a couple of clicks i have access to
my governed and trusted looker data in
sheets and i can easily connect to my
data models
to understand which factors are
impacting sales i'll drag and drop
fields from my model into a pivot table
to break out sales by category over time
since it's pulling from looker i can
trust that all the data definitions are
consistent i can use familiar sheets
formulas and formatting to get insights
faster and understand how specific
products are selling
we see a notable downward trend month
over month for activewear i want to
share these findings with my marketing
team who's using tableau
now i can use the new tableau and looker
integration to combine data for my
looker data model with marketing data to
build a more comprehensive view of my
business
next i'm going to plot sales by category
and then add marketing spend to the view
tableau makes it easy for me to drill
down on relevant data now i can see that
social marketing spend was significantly
lower for activewear and this is why
there's a downward trend in activewear
sales
i'm going to publish this result on
tableau online and tag my marketing team
so they can take action
leveraging integrations between tableau
sheets and looker allows our teams to
build powerful visualizations using
trusted data we can then share these
visualizations throughout our
organization to drive informed decisions
action and impact back over to you
thomas
thank you alex
the second questions customers ask
do we have industry leading technology
infrastructure
we're experiencing great momentum with
our open infrastructure cloud
many of the most demanding and
technically advanced customers in the
world
disproportionately choose us
take for example leading media companies
and streaming services such as univision
and global
the largest media group in latin america
they use our high performance networking
computing and storage to broadcast media
including live events such as the recent
tokyo olympics
leading telecommunications companies are
also choosing google cloud
reliance geo the world's second largest
mobile carrier is automating its 5g
network
vodafone is processing over a billion
network events each day
at t
is delivering new multi-access edge
computing solutions
and telus is migrating critical i t and
network workloads
all to google cloud
you know leading data management
companies including data bricks redis
cockroach labs couch base elastic influx
data maria db mongodb neo4j and single
store
are all growing faster on google cloud
than on any other cloud
and they love our storage scalability
and advanced infrastructure
mongodb for instance
has more net new customers
via google cloud marketplace
than on any other cloud
leading cyber security companies such as
palo alto networks
exaby fy shape splunk broadcom and
forgerock
are also choosing google cloud for its
performance
global scale
and underlying security
customers are migrating and transforming
sap
and vmware workloads to google cloud
in just the last year we've added three
times the number of sap customers
as the prior year
and were exhilarating
paypal for instance has an sap hana
scale out system
supporting 40 million business
transactions daily
200 billion records
touched in just 30 seconds
mitel in canada
migrated over 1 000
vmware virtual machines in less than 90
days
to google cloud vmware engine
nilas
an api platform company
chose our tile virtual machines
along with google kubernetes engine as
they saw over 40 percent better price
performance than in a competitor
you know customers choose our open cloud
infrastructure
for three main reasons
first
we make your path to migrate and
modernize using cloud easy
with migration tools
new serverless and container
capabilities
and managed services
as your developers spend more time
building experiences
that your customers love
second we offer transformative
capabilities with cutting edge
performance and security
and our network offers
three times the throughput of other
cloud providers
third we remain
and were the very first
and only cloud provider with a clear
multi-cloud strategy
we provide you with a consistent
developer experience
built an open source to write once and
deploy anywhere
many customers like plaid
a financial services leader
use anthos
to deploy
operate and manage applications across
multiple clouds
recently we introduced anthos for
virtual machines
standardizing the way that you manage
applications
across both virtual machines and
containers
for multi-cloud data
bigquery omni
lets customers analyze data
across google cloud
aws
to migrate data
customers also want to expand where they
use google cloud
whether in their private data centers or
out on the edge
for instance some workloads
cannot move to the public cloud entirely
due to the need for large amounts of
local data processing
extremely low latency or strict
regulations
to solve these challenges we're
announcing today
google distributed cloud
a portfolio of hardware and software
solutions
that extend our infrastructure to the
edge
and even into your own data center
to tell you more about it please welcome
inez from our google cloud distributed
cloud team
thank you thomas
google distributed cloud is a set of
fully managed services running on google
managed hardware based on open apis and
built on antos it gives customers
greater deployment flexibility and
ensures more consistent operations
across hybrid and multi-cloud
environments more than any other cloud
provider there are four deployment
scenarios depending on your specific
needs
google's network edge this allows
customers to leverage over 140 network
edge locations around the world
operator ads this scenario is designed
to accommodate emerging services and
applications with a stringent latency
and reliability requirements for a
specific operator
customer ads this scenario supports
customer owned edge locations such as
retail stores factory floors or branch
offices which require localized compute
and processing and finally customer data
centers this deployment option is
specific to customer owned data centers
and color facilities google distributed
cloud also includes a hosted mode to run
sensitive workloads and address data
sovereignty security and privacy
requirements it does not require
connectivity to google cloud at any time
to manage infrastructure services apis
or tooling
you have the choice to manage it
yourself or host through a designated
trusted partner
back to you thomas
thank you inez
partners like hpe
dell cisco and netapp are key as we
deploy google distributed cloud globally
on best-in-class hardware
i'm pleased to announce the expansion of
our partnership with network appliance
in two important ways
first netapp is our primary partner
supporting google's distributed cloud
storage infrastructure
second for customers using google cloud
vmware engine
they now have preview access for netapp
cloud volumes
we are the only hyperscaler to provide
customers with this choice
deep partnerships with t-systems and
tolus
have also enabled us to address the
evolving
sovereignty requirements for cloud
technology in germany and france
the next question we hear
is how can we provide the best
environment
to help employees create and innovate
together especially in a hybrid
workplace you know hybrid is redefining
how we all work
making it less about where we work
but more about the quality of our
experience
studies estimate that more than 48
percent of employees will work remotely
post covet
google workspace is the best platform
for hybrid work
with simple
powerful and secure tools to help people
communicate and collaborate with one
another no matter where they are
we introduce smart canvas
to help content creators remove friction
from workflows and enable teams to stay
connected outside of meetings
to foster well-being and reduce video
call fatigue
we made communication and collaboration
completely seamless
for instance users can easily present
and collaborate in meetings
create meeting notes from their calendar
present and meet directly from dog
sheets or slides and collaborate
directly from chat and spaces
we optimize collaboration from all
mobile devices
to provide great experiences
for frontline workers who make up 80
percent of the global workforce
one of america's largest hospital
systems common spirit health
is advancing its mission during the
pandemic by making its frontline doctors
and nurses productive with google
workspace
since hybrid work has removed the notion
of a physical location for work
google workspace created spaces
a unified digital location for work
today more than 3 billion users
move securely and seamlessly between
mail
chat audio video and now spaces
and you too
can choose among the over 5 300
public apps in our marketplace
and you can also add thousands of
private apps
to enhance your workspace
now i want to step aside for just a
minute
and tell you about a hidden secret
in our portfolio products
app sheet
our no code platform that makes it easy
for everyone
not just professional developers
to build amazing apps and workflows
for instance property managers at car4
properties
used app sheet
to build a mobile app
to log track and resolve problems with
headquarters
replacing a multi-step manual process
we're also partnering with citrix
because employees sometimes need access
to windows and mac os applications and
desktops
directly served from the cloud
we're expanding our partnership with
citrix today to deliver an integrated
desktop as a service solution
purpose built on google cloud
now customers ask us
do we know that our data systems and
users are secure
and how do we keep them secure
in the future
you know as more digital users
access more data from more locations
the risk of cyber security breaches is
exhilarating
by pioneering new approaches to security
google keeps more people safe online
than anyone else in the world
take for instance jet blue
it's keeping its system secure
protecting the data of all its travelers
and modernizing its security operations
using chronicle
to detect threats
across petabytes of security telemetry
eliminating data blind spots
commence bank
one of germany's largest banks
is using our new certificate authority
service
to verify machine
and workload identity
improving security simplifying
operations eliminating entire classes of
threats
secure by default drives customers to
choose google cloud
first we've implemented zero trust at
the core of our services and our
operations enabling you to trust nothing
second we've built cloud scale threat
detection and response allowing you to
detect everything
and third we know it's not just about
tools
we provide the advisory services you
need to transform security operations
we keep customers safe with beyond corp
enterprise which enables zero trust
access for all your users
today we're expanding beyond corp to all
your applications
modern in legacy
web and desktop
and even to production environments
we keep customers safe by eliminating
software supply chain vulnerabilities
over the past two decades
we pioneered an approach to secure our
own software supply chain
we are now making that technology
available
through the salsa open source framework
and as managed services on our cloud to
help you
secure your own software supply chain
we keep customers safe by integrating
chronicles threat detection capability
with our security command center
allowing you to respond faster to
potential risks
and we keep customers safe
by bringing our security expertise to
you
with our google cyber security action
team
a team of our leading security experts
who can help shape your security
transformation
from your very first implementation
through responding to a major incident
and engineering new solutions
as needs change
finally
we continue to expand our security
ecosystem with companies like fortinet
palo alto networks tolus and so many
more
today i'd like to welcome a new security
partner
cyber reason with whom we are
collaborating to deliver a new extended
detection and response offering
that will combine chronicles capability
with cyber reasons malops engine
for faster easier threat detection and
response
our products
our new cyber security action team
and our partnerships
all make the world safer from cyber
threats
to talk more about how we help keep
each and every one of you secure
and how we're addressing
some of the most important challenges
facing our world
i'd like to invite sundar back
thank you
thank you thomas
security is top of mind for businesses
of all sizes
as well as the public sector
and despite the progress that has been
made in cyber security
large-scale breaches continue to make
headlines
that's why in august google announced
we'll invest 10 billion dollars over the
next five years to strengthen cyber
security
that includes expanding zero trust
programs
helping secure the software supply chain
and enhancing open source security
a new challenge is keeping collaboration
secure and private as we move to hybrid
work environments
to help we are introducing a new work
safer program
it provides the highest level of
security for your email
meetings messaging and more
and brings together google workspace
with tight end security keys beyond corp
and other secure technologies products
and partners
now every kind of organization and
business can access the same security
protections that make work safer at
google
security is an issue that affects us all
and this brings us to the last question
thomas posed
are we addressing the most important
challenges facing our world
climate change is one of the most
profound challenges we face
it'll take all of us working together to
solve it
sustainability has been a core value for
us for more than two decades
google has been carbon neutral since
2007
and we've matched our operations with
hundred percent renewable energy over
four consecutive years
last year we set out to make our third
decade of climate action our biggest yet
that included a bold commitment to
operate on 24 7 carbon free energy
across our offices and data centers by
2030
and last week we announced new ways we
are helping one billion people make more
sustainable choices
when it comes to enterprises one of the
most important sustainability choices is
where to run your technology
idc predicts
cloud migrations over the next four
years
could reduce carbon emissions by over 1
billion metric tons
or the equivalent of removing 200
million cars off the road for a year
we are proud that google cloud is the
cleanest cloud in the industry earlier
this year we introduced a way for
customers
to choose the cleanest regions to run
their workloads
today we are expanding our portfolio of
solutions and partnerships to help
reduce your carbon footprint
first we have focused on giving you
greater transparency around carbon
emissions data
we are announcing carbon footprint a new
service to measure
track and report the gross carbon
emissions associated with your google
cloud usage
having this data at your fingertips is
really important
and we know that many customers track
sustainability data in other places
that's why i'm happy to announce that
google cloud emission data
will integrate directly into salesforce
sustainability cloud
we also want to give you the tools to
act on the data
so today we are introducing a new tool
that will alert you when you have idle
workloads and make recommendations to
reduce carbon emissions
it's all part of our goal to help make
your cloud transformation secure and
sustainable
and solve for what's next
so on behalf of thomas and myself
let me thank you once again for trusting
us to be a partner with you on this
journey and we hope you enjoy the next
three days
thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to our very first
spotlight i hope you enjoyed the opening
keynote for the next hour we will be
diving into all things data i'm
stephanie wong a developer advocate and
i'm here with garrett casbaier who leads
database analytics and bi solutions at
google cloud
thanks stephanie i'm very excited to be
here and to share with everyone what we
have been working on
the team thought we start on the light
side of things here and start with a
joke one of my favorite jokes actually
so
here it goes a secret query walks into a
bar and approaches two tables and asks
can i join you
[Music]
okay i guess we wrote a video instead
[Music]
innovation is a huge challenge in
baseball the current mlb fan expects us
to be relevant customers call us
patients call us members call us and you
can imagine a team that's just buried
under the weight of thousands of call
recordings
we look at so much data everything you
can imagine we analyze frankly we spend
70 percent of our time
just trying to to capture it and trying
to sift through it we're expecting to
transfer around 300 to 400 petabytes to
the cloud
it's hard to even describe how big that
is
google cloud was very impressive to us
it allowed us flexibility in storage and
compute scaling google cloud provides us
with technology that will drive us to be
better
now our team can look at hundreds of
calls a day in minutes instead of weeks
with google cloud we're going to be able
to spend our time analyzing real time
and using the data that we've been
collecting
we thought google cloud was the best
partner for us
i think this is very much going to be an
open and evolving long-term relationship
between google and twitter it's a
perfect fit with google cloud as we go
forward google's made it possible for us
to reach exceptional customer experience
in a way that hasn't been done before
[Music]
and welcome back so what are we solving
for today this spotlight session is
about how to leverage data as your most
strategic business asset especially as
you adapt to and anticipate change
data has the power to transform stagnant
businesses into profitable ones
streamline operations to improve
people's lives and identify areas of
waste to radically reduce unnecessary
spending it can be used to solve
businesses and world problems both the
simple ones and the ones that keep
people up at night
it has the potential to accelerate
progress faster than a think tank or
world summit and it's largely untapped
as you learn more about google cloud
capabilities and make progress on your
data cloud journey you can unlock your
own 10x mindset as external factors
accelerate the pace of change
never before have we faced this much
uncertainty and now is the time when
every company can turn data into an
ability
the reality today is that too many
companies struggle to remove the
barriers to turn data into intelligence
this is exactly what we are seeing with
our customers turning data into
intelligence and delivering value is no
longer a nice to have it is essential a
recent study shows that only 32 of the
companies surveyed gain value from their
data investments
and this is the result of difficult to
access slow unreliable complex and
fragmented systems
many companies just feel overwhelmed
with the demand for the various types of
working with data and of doing it at
scale they feel walled in with a lack of
integration a lack of openness a lack of
portability and very poor apis
it is time to reimagine our data cloud
strategy that is unlocking your data
advantage build great applications that
understand and interact with your
customer on operational databases that
scale to billions of queries per second
react on any event in real time and
process millions of data streams analyze
petabytes of data without sizing or
tuning your data warehouse anymore and
ultimately optimize your processes with
hundreds of machine learning models in
production
this is how you unlock your data cloud
and unlock your data advantage
to build your data cloud you need your
systems to be simple
and this requires a partner that meets
you where you are today and helps you to
mature
where you want to be but at your own
pace
making the complex simple is our
business
it has been for decades building systems
that mask the complexity of the entire
internet behind a simple single
interface and building applications with
billions of users
it all runs on data and analytics so you
can say the data is our dna
and we can't predict the future but we
can plan for it and we are deeply
grateful to work with tens of thousands
of organizations who build their data
clouds on google cloud and unlock
ultimately their data advantage from
databases to analytics to streams to
lakes to ai and build a unified data
cloud together with us
it's leaders like you who are
accelerating their use of data to
transform complexity into simplicity
this week at next you'll hear from
leading organizations that have chosen
google cloud for their data cloud
strategy over market alternatives
verizon media is one of these customers
verizon uses bigquery and looker to
scale their massive enterprise media
warehouse supporting monthly scans of
more than one exabyte of data
the performance improvements include
90
plus productivity improvements across
the board and lower overall tco compared
to other cloud providers
almost overnight traffic to chess.com
tripled the pandemic and successful
series the queen's gambit created a
perfect storm
10 years worth of growth occurred in
just six months and daily active users
rose from 280 000 to more than 1 million
there's no way to handle that search
without the move to google cloud using
bigquery's near infinite ability to
scale in response to demand this meant
that chess.com didn't have to forecast
site traffic and worry about unexpected
surges or waste money by over
provisioning servers that go unused take
autotrader it's uk's largest online
automotive marketplace and they were
able to migrate more than 60 percent of
their current oracle footprint to cloud
sql autotrader builds their data cloud
by leveraging cloud sql bigquery and
looker to deliver access to their data
to all of their users
and with cloud sql as a fully managed
service audit radar release cadence has
improved by over 130 percent year over
year enabling an impressive peak of more
than 450 releases to production
on a single day and this is how you
build your data advantage
when cardinal health migrated to google
cloud they enabled disaster recovery
increased their ability to respond to
business challenges and leverage machine
learning to drive business efficiencies
all while reducing their cost by 25
we would like to welcome ray bajaj cto
of cardinal health to share their data
transformation story
ray thank you so much for joining us
here today
thanks stephanie and i'm really happy to
be here today cardinal health is a
pioneer in healthcare industry for
leveraging the cloud as our primary
source of
infrastructure
achieving our cloud transformation
journey goal
with more than 80 percent of our
workload
fully migrated onto the cloud
our journey to google cloud started in
2018
leveraging the security and flexibility
of google cloud
allows us to scale and innovate at lower
cost
which empowers our organization to focus
on building the future of healthcare
and driving better outcomes across the
healthcare ecosystem so
why google cloud
with google we can deliver modern data
insights capabilities
to our engineering teams
so that they can transform our core
business
while also improving the customer
experience
helping the organization evolve
in the adjacent areas of healthcare
we also selected google cloud because of
its ability to partner with sap
and run massive erp workloads reliably
now what outcomes have you been able to
realize as a result of this
we leverage google's local and bigquery
to develop episode analytics a data
driven predictive cost tracking tool
that enables community oncology
practices
to accurately measure
the cost of care and provides clearer
insights into value-based performance
well ray cardinal is clearly at the
forefront of these shifts and we can't
wait to see what's in store for you so
thank you so much for being here with us
today
thank you
organizations like cardinal health are
solving complex challenges with google
cloud
but
what is holding others back from using
data to accelerate innovation
companies are looking for solutions that
can simplify their data landscape to
move from a state where every scenario
requires a new tool to an agile platform
that combines data analytics databases
data engineering and science security
and governance into a single platform
to move from data at rest to a platform
where data is accessible in real time
our vision is to provide a platform that
allows data to unfold its full potential
ultimately enabling us to reach new
horizons ranging from newly built
digital experiences products and
business models to advanced machine
learning and ai to ultimately empowering
humans to reason beyond their own
biological capacity
and we have built the industry's most
simple intelligent and best integrated
cloud data platform that enables
businesses to fuel their own digital
transformation
and this is how you unlock your data
advantage
to seize new opportunities improve
operational efficiencies and deliver new
user experiences that delight customers
partners
and your employees
thanks to you our customers and partners
google's data platform is one of the
fastest growing clouds fueled by the
demand for products like bigquery and
here comes the most exciting part today
we are excited to announce a number of
new product innovations
and the first announcement goes out to
all of the data engineers in the world
who are using spark on google cloud
open standards are at the heart of our
data cloud strategy and at google we
follow an open approach that enables
flexibility and choice
and today i am excited to announce
project big spark it is the world first
auto scaling serverless spark service in
existence
and regardless of whether you are a big
query user a data proc user or a cloud
ai user we have created an integrated
ecosystem around spark that defacto
standard for data engineering workloads
we want to make it easy for you to
onboard on our platform with spark and
never limit your ambition with data
science and data engineering
our long history in the open source
community has shown us that betting on
the community first is always the right
strategy to give our customers
portability and optionality
we're excited to make spark a
first-class citizen on our platform and
to automate the productionalization of
your data engineering and data science
workloads
the next announcement goes to all of the
data scientists
as enterprises consolidate their data
platforms the distinction between
advanced analytics and data science and
machine learning is really diminishing
today more than ever data scientists are
looking for a unified interface to be
able to seamlessly connect their entire
data estate and also run all
explorations with sql spark and other
machine learning libraries with vertex
ai we have simplified the experience for
data scientists with 80 percent less
code required to drain a model compared
to any other platform
as a part of google's vertex ai strategy
i am happy to announce the brief view of
a.i notebook for vertex ci that offers a
fully managed scalable and enterprise
great ide combined with easily
enforceable policies and user management
these ai notebook innovations are great
examples of google bringing together the
power of data and ai google truly aims
to fast-track innovation by eliminating
the need for data scientists to shift
contacts between aspects like data
analytics data science and machine
learning
that is right on and here is an exciting
announcement to all of the developers
we are adding a postgres interface for
spanner which continues our commitment
to openness and reinforces our efforts
to democratize the access to spanner
with this new postgres interface
enterprises can take advantage of
spanner's unmatched global scale five
nines of availability and strong
consistency using skills and tools from
the popular postgres ecosystem and
starting today you can create a spanner
database that uses postgresql dialect
and connect with its open wire protocol
this interface supports banner's rich
feature set using the most popular
postgres data types and sql features and
thus democratizing access to spanner for
millions of developers out there our
commitment to the ecosystem has been
long standing with ongoing support for
cloud sql for mysql postgres and sql
server so you can lift and shift your
databases
our mission with cloud sql is
compatibility and we were the first
cloud provider to support postgres 13.
these announcements are so exciting
because postgres has emerged as a
popular choice for operational databases
postgres is known and love for its
stability and feature set and has built
an active and growing ecosystem of
developers and tools
our investments in postgres are a step
in the right direction to continue
meeting developers where they are with
the tools they love we are excited to
announce new ways to help organizations
going beyond traditional business
intelligence to analyze access and act
on data looker continues to integrate
with the other offerings in our
portfolio as well as continues to
innovate with our core product and to
address the needs we are continuing to
simplify the experience across bigquery
looker and data studio together with
connected sheets today we are announcing
new enhancements which bring the reality
of augmented analytics to more people
with looker solution for contact center
ai to help businesses leverage ai and
converse naturally with customers and
deliver outstanding experiences
we are also announcing a new looker
block for healthcare nlp ai which
creates a user interface to advanced ai
in natural language functionality and
this helps healthcare providers to gain
deeper understandings of their patient
data part of the secret sauce lies in
lookers in database architecture and the
semantic layer which makes it possible
for business users to trust data no
matter how they experience it
via a dashboard email or text alert or
even a custom application
we are excited for these recent
innovations but we couldn't do this
alone
together with our community of customers
partners and developers we are
delivering innovation across a variety
of use cases we are able to create new
solutions and accelerate your journey to
transform data
into value
next i want to announce an important
partnership with informatica we have
partnered with informatica to help
hundreds of customers succeed with their
journey to the cloud
together we are helping customers move
mission critical workloads to the cloud
and integrate with google cloud
technologies such as bigquery
today we are excited to announce that we
are deepening our partnership with
informatica even more
first for existing informatica power
center customers we are so pleased to
announce our migration factory which
will help to accelerate migration of
data driven workloads to google cloud
with informatica cloud
second we are pleased to announce our
new services on google cloud's
marketplace which will include
informatica's integration and enterprise
data catalog offerings
and we are continuing to invest in key
product integrations with data bricks
our engineering and product teams
continue to work together to deliver the
joint roadmap and we have multiple
customers using our latest enterprise
security and performance enhancements of
databricks on gke
in q4 we will also deliver data brick
sql databricks photon on google cloud as
well as we are launching new data center
regions together in emea and apec
our ai teams are engaged to allow
customers to experiment and develop
models on data bricks and vertex ai
together and deploy models at scale into
production with vertex ml ops suite so
much goodness okay before we get into
the live demo i recommend tuning in to
more sessions to hear from all our
customers this week join the chief data
officer panel discussion and listen to
our product strategy sessions for
database data analytics bi and ai
we can't wait to hear from you connect
with you join us in our community and
share your expertise and ask you
questions but most importantly start to
build your data cloud and unlock your
data advantage
okay
time now to get hands on and check out
our products in real action
join us for live demo and interact with
our experts and one another and then
stick around for the live q a following
the demo
i see you there
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
hi everybody i'm leah and i'm nikita and
welcome to the data cloud live demo
if you're just joining us from this
morning's keynote and spotlight you
heard some of the latest innovations we
launched
earth engine spark on google cloud
postgres sql interface for spanner and
vertex ai workbench all to help
organizations solve their most complex
data-driven challenges
in this live demo we're going to take
complex fragmented data systems and
simplify them bringing together data on
a massive scale to explore a real-world
scenario for climate and supply chain
analytics in order to do this we're
going to need the whole data team say hi
everyone
hello i'm brad
hi i'm derek
now a quick reminder this demo is truly
live and you can engage with us directly
so ask questions say hi in the chat
window and hit those emojis
i think i see some coming in now i see
lots of hearts and fire a lot of people
saying hello in the chat thanks everyone
for joining us today
so if you can't see the emojis or the
chat just go back to the next event
website and click on the blue join the
interactive experience button
okay
let's have a little fun with this
today you're actually joining us for our
weekly stand up at symbol superstore a
fictional us-based grocery chain focused
on sourcing from local producers
like many different industries we need
to bring together disparate data sources
to build resilience
specifically for us drought in the
western u.s has impacted our producers
and our supply chain has been disrupted
with decreased shipments week over week
we need to better understand how to
manage inventory and to prevent
stockouts and ensure we can scale in
both how we analyze information and how
we run our transactions
all right team so to address the supply
and scale challenges that nikita just
mentioned we have four different
workloads
first i'm going to evaluate the best
climate information to identify at-risk
producers
then brad will mature our data pipelines
to transform that data
next derrick will dig into scaling our
transaction processing and finally
nikita will show how we're gaining new
insights by evolving our data science
capabilities
let's get into it and let's keep hearing
from all of you out there our data pros
leah you're up first great thanks nikita
so in order to gain insight into our
supply chain first i need to evaluate
the risks so i'm focusing on figuring
out how drought impacts the very source
of our grocery products
and to do this i turned to google's
platform for earth science data and
analytics earth engine which has a huge
catalog of satellite images for things
like climate weather croplands and much
more
there's currently over like 50 petabytes
of data in the catalog
plus more and more images are added each
day
so let me just go ahead and bring up
this cool little application that i
built using the earth engine code editor
so i can walk you through the three data
sets we'll be using today
first is going to be crop data from the
usda nass program which i can grab right
from the public data catalog by
searching
so this data set is going to contain one
image of the us for each year going back
all the way to 1997.
and each 10 meter pixel in this image
has actually been assigned a crop type
let me just close out of this here bring
you back to my app so the second data
set contains the outline of agricultural
fields and we're going to use earth
engine to assign each one of these
fields the crop type that is most
prevalent among the cells that cover it
so in this view that i'm showing right
here the pink fields are alfalfa and the
dark green fields are almonds leah these
visuals are super super helpful but can
we export this data for analysis in
other environments yep i'm actually
going to push this into cloud storage
and bigquery in just a sec but first i
want to add in some additional signals
on drought
so the third data set that i'm using is
a collection of both short and long term
drought indicators meaning that we can
see what drought looks like for each
field over time
now using data sets like these does
require some deep subject matter
expertise so special thanks to our real
world partners at climate engine who
build solutions on top of earth engines
api
helping organizations ground their
analytics projects with scientifically
accepted methodologies
okay so you just saw how we use
geospatial data and i want to know how
you use it in your analysis so go ahead
and answer that poll so we can see
all right everyone so with these layers
in place we can start exploring drought
risk
let me just go ahead and zoom to this
field
and here i'm going to show an almond
orchard northeast of modesto california
and what we're looking at is the
long-term drought indicator so this
orange tint that you're seeing means
that this field has experienced pretty
high levels of drought over the last
five years
now if i go ahead and just zoom out a
bit
we can actually see that the entire
central valley in california is pretty
drought stressed
so my last step was to calculate drought
risk for each of the fields i showed
before and this will tell us which farms
and produce types are potentially at
risk for not meeting customer demand
which is just one consideration to
inform symbols resilient strategy
better yet we can incorporate the
geography data with other spatial stuff
like store and customer locations that
are already inside of bigquery
and anyone who knows me knows that i
love bigquery if you agree let me see in
the emojis
all right so the code editor has been
great for interacting with earth engine
but making these calculations at scale
requires a different approach
so i went ahead and created earth engine
tasks for batch processing to run these
calculations over all the data in
five-day increments for the past ten
years
i also set up a cloud function to run
every five days going forward so that
we'll always have fresh data
now just as a quick recap we jumped into
earth engine to evaluate earth science
data that indicates climate risk for our
farm fields
now we'll have fresh drought data
available in cloud storage
so just think of the power of
integrating huge amounts of specialized
data giving us a complete picture of
supply risk for our business
oh and i think i can see the poll
results coming in now
it looks like lots of people are using
geospatial data for all different kinds
of things and if your answer wasn't in
the poll just go ahead and let us know
in the chat
so next up brad will transform and push
this data into bigquery for geospatial
analysis with our existing data
so brad over to you
okay that was pretty cool leah thanks
all right
so to gain more insight into how drought
is impacting production my main focus
has been building out the data
transformation pipeline to push farm
field drought indicators from cloud
storage into bigquery
speaking of batch processing as you know
to assist with inventory management
price optimization and product
assortment we use spark to standardize
our large scale data processing and we
use google cloud data proc as our
long-running clusters
for you data pros out there we'd love to
know how you're using spark today so let
us know while i go ahead and pull up the
cloud console
so here is a data cluster we currently
use to schedule pi spark jobs
and here i'm connected to a jupyter
notebook running on the same cluster
with some pi spark code this code is
typical boilerplate code you'd write to
do basic data transformations in this
case we are processing the earth engine
files from cloud storage performing type
checking and mapping to ensure proper
ingestion into bigquery using the spark
bigquery connector
hey brad so this is pretty cool but i
think having a batch workflow that's
scheduled on a continuously running
cluster seems like it can be kind of
wasteful so is there any way we can make
this more efficient that's a fair point
leah there is still some overhead and
management here
and for hardened batch cases like this
it would be preferred to have these jobs
run on their own discrete resources
but good news with the new serverless
option for dataproc we can submit a pi
spark job without spinning up any
infrastructure these auto magic
capabilities i can spend more dev time
writing code and less time on managing
infrastructure
all right brad first off i'm pretty sure
that you just set me up for that and
second you definitely made up that word
automagic
yeah can i get some emoji love for that
anyway i'll now go ahead and export this
notebook to a python file using nb
convert
okay and next let's go and use the cloud
sdk to submit a serverless price mark
job we can use the dataproc api and call
batches to submit a serverless job
so i'm showing you here a pi spark job
but i can also submit spark jobs written
in scala java r or sql
with auto provision and auto scale no
infrastructure configuration is needed
this helps those less familiar with how
to fine tune their smart jobs to utilize
its powerful distributed data processing
model with these capabilities there's no
need to manually create and tune
clusters
so once i've submitted the job i can
show it listed in the serverless spark
console and i can click on the job to
view its logs
now serverless spark takes about a
minute or so to auto provision the
resources as well as start writing out
log output so what i'll go ahead and do
here is show you the log output from a
completed job that i ran earlier
so if we click in here we can see okay
so i added some print statements into
this job and here it's showing me that
there's some short-term drought data
that's processed some long-term drought
data and then some geographical data
as well
now in addition to this i can also show
you the spark history server which is
where the more details of the spark job
itself will be
outputted once the job has been
completed so we can go back and debug
and then additionally we can also gain
access to metadata via data proc
metastore
now in addition to all of this we are
also looking into a new solution for
creating long-running clusters or a
place where our infrastructure team can
manage dataproc clusters
now fortunately we feel that spark on
gke fits our use case and lets us
utilize our existing gke infrastructure
so clearly it's been a busy week for me
using spark serverless to create
pipelines to push drought data into
bigquery but the efficiency improvements
we'll gain by not needing to manage
cluster overhead will be worth it
now you can let me know in the chat if
you're as excited about spark serverless
as i am
okay let's see how everyone's using
spark today
looks like notebooks are pretty popular
oh and automation through airflow that's
cool too
okay great thanks so much brad so now
that we have greater insight into supply
risks we need to scale our transaction
systems to handle more orders and allow
us to understand the potential business
impact of these climate risks while
hopefully lowering costs
so this brings me to derek our dba
derek you've been focusing on this
effort so can you let us know where
you're at today
yeah absolutely leah
we have a new grocery chain that has
struggled to maintain their on-prem
databases as they've grown
there's an opportunity to solve their
underlying scaling problems with cloud
spanner
i spent the last few weeks validating
spanner's ability to scale and the ease
of maintenance while keeping strong
consistency for this point of sale
workload
i migrated some of the new chain stores
to spanner already using granular
instance sizing i only provisioned a
portion of a spanner node to handle the
required load
as we move the remainder of stores we
can easily scale up without downtime or
app changes
quick question derek we've been really
focused on reducing the cost and
complexity of building scalable
applications so i'm wondering how does
adding spanner impact that effort
yeah that's a great question nikita
one way we've been doing this in other
environments is to standardize on
postgres
postgres is a well-established open
source database with an active ecosystem
that our development and ops teams are
already familiar with
i tried to get the team to add an
elephant emoji so y'all could show some
love for postgres
but anyway
spanner just announced a poster sql
interface this gives us the benefits of
spanner without having to completely
retrain our application teams
having a standard api for our data will
help us maintain velocity for new
features even as our database needs
evolve here let me show you
so i've connected into our spanner
instance using the psql command line
tool
from here i can explore the schema just
like i would any other database
any other postgres database
you can see that the both the postgres
data type and the spanner data type is
available to the information schema
so
this will make it familiar to anyone who
already knows postgres
awesome thanks derek this is really cool
i'm really looking forward to the
scalability that this is going to bring
our team
absolutely
and as a quick summary i highlighted how
to spanner allows us to get started
small and scale as needed using granular
instant sizing and how the new
postgresql interface reduces friction
for our teams already familiar with
postgres
nikita and leah you can treat the
existing data as golden and i'll keep
onboarding more stores
uh nikita i believe you need this data
for some of the big query analysis you
were working on
you've been busy figuring out how to
evolve our ability to make sense of all
this data can you show us how that works
yes absolutely i was hoping that you'd
ask so to ensure that we're managing
stock to meet customer demand my focus
this week was on evolving our data
science capabilities for exploratory
analysis
i combine the transactional data that
derek's been working on with the drought
data that leah and brad pushed into
bigquery
this way we can gain insight into which
products are most at risk of not meeting
customer demand
so my first step was to integrate all of
our transactional data within bigquery
primarily using federation with cloud
sql and spanner
this provides a unified environment for
aggregation and analysis where we can
join transactions back to producer
details and the associated drought risk
scores
now as you all know we recently migrated
to vertex ai workbench which has really
really helped with our basic compute and
resource management
quick question nikita is vertex ai
workbench a notebook for vertex ai that
is an excellent question derek vertex ai
workbench contains recently updated
managed notebooks which bring forth more
integrated data engineering capabilities
into our data science environments
so we can ingest and analyze data and
deploy and manage ml models all from one
spot
now let me show you a little bit about
what this looks like after i provisioned
a new managed notebook my first task was
to analyze the demand on the high volume
skus and for that i used the bigquery
connector to view and query the sales
data
with vertex ai workbench i can inspect
bigquery metadata preview tables and
automate basic sql construction entirely
from my notebook environment
okay it's my turn on the emojis i want
to see the fire emoji from all the data
scientists out there who are as excited
as i am about being able to access
bigquery from the notebook interface
looks like i'm not the only one
hey nikita hold on sorry to interrupt
your emoji fest but i see you're working
out of the lakes project but are able to
pin other projects you have access to
like the ops project is that new
yes that's correct brad vertex ai
workbench actually enables me to
interact with all services via my own
identity
the bigquery plugin also provides some
templated code to help build out queries
and project results to a pandas data
frame so here we can see oh looks like i
just need to refresh
sorry about that team i'm just going to
refresh my jupiter lab instance here i
guess i had it open for too long and i
guess while nikita's doing that like who
uses jupiter now let's see the fire
emojis lighting up
i see so now
i personally use it a lot in my day
today all right thank you so perfect now
you can see a simple view of all
transactions by the day of week
um and vertex workbench actually also
allows me to launch different kernels
entirely in the same instance so brad i
think you were working out of a pi spark
notebook earlier is that correct
yeah so data proc clusters are also
supported as a back end as a part of
spark on google cloud we can access all
supported kernels on the cluster
including price park
well for my analysis i just needed a
python kernel so let me show you what's
going on in this notebook and what i've
been up to this week
you can see here that i've done a deep
dive into the data i've plotted the
transaction volume i've created a heap
map of purchase counts across various
departments and i've also plotted the
short-term drought index across various
crop types like corn dry beans pears and
rice
but my last task and the most important
task was to map skus to suppliers and
calculate a risk score based on the
aggregate field data
so to do this i started with our mapping
table which you can see a sample of
right here this helped me to determine
which farm fields actually source
ingredients for a particular skew
and then i calculated a weighted risk
score that takes into account each
product's demand and the associated
farms overall drought risk and you can
see each of these measurements in this
data frame right here
ultimately this score will help us to
prioritize managing items where we're
most at risk of not meeting customer
demand
so as a quick summary i used vertex ai
workbench manage notebooks to connect
back to data accessible from bigquery
and create a weighted risk score for
each one of our products combining both
climate and demand data
leah i went ahead and put all this back
into bigquery just to keep it
centralized
awesome thanks so much nikita that risk
score is going to be huge in helping our
team understand supply risk
so to make sure the broader team has a
trusted view of all this information i
started incorporating everything into a
looker dashboard
now with looker we define our metrics
like average risk using lookml looker's
data model
and looker uses this to compile sql
queries and send them back to bigquery
on our behalf so that our non-technical
users can explore the results of these
data efforts
so let me show you this dashboard that
i've been working on and first off you
can see this custom map layer that i use
to visualize drought risk across farm
regions in the west
and we're able to take advantage of
bigquery's geospatial functions and
drill from this aggregate view all the
way to producer or even grocery product
level
let me show you so i'll drill to field
id
and then i can jump right into lookers
explore to bring in some more fields
like maybe i want to specifically look
at products that are at risk
in this region where we're quickly
expanding
making all this data accessible to the
broader team is really important so can
we make sure that the marketing team is
aware of this so they they know how to
hold off on coupons or advertisements
for these products yeah actually we can
set up a schedule from looker so that
the regional marketing teams are always
notified if new products seem to go at
risk
so putting this all together we used
earth engine to process new earth
science data signals we use spark to
efficiently transform geospatial data
and push drought indicators into
bigquery
spanner to scale our transaction systems
ensuring we have the infrastructure to
handle future growth
and vertex ai workbench plus looker
backed by the power of bigquery to
evolve our data science capabilities and
surface important trends back to key
decision makers
so with integrations across these
services anyone is able to explore and
take action on insights that combine
climate data and transactions
now we can understand where products may
go out of stock due to increasing
drought conditions and identify areas to
build resilience against changes in our
climate
so with this geospatial information
we're given a whole new set of data so
that we can not only be considerate of
our customers but also find ways to be
more considerate of our planet
and with that it looks like we're right
about at time so thank you so much for
joining us today as we've shown how
google cloud can offer a world-class
experience for creating a scalable
unified data platform
and a special thanks to my colleagues
nikita for showing us vertex ai
workbench
derek for introducing us to spanner and
its postgres interoperability and brad
for walking us through spark on google
cloud and thank you leah for showing us
looker and earth engine
last but certainly not least thank you
all out there so much for your
engagement we love those emojis and
seeing all of your comments in the chat
so stay tuned for our live q a which is
going to cover everything from our
spotlight through this demo
thank you thanks everyone thanks bye
[Music]
thanks so much data cloud team what a
cool demo i'm dane hansen welcome
everyone i'm the director of product
marketing for data cloud joining me
today is garrett kasmeier garrett hey
dane i'm garrett i'm the vice president
of data analytics databases and looker
and i do look forward to everyone's
questions i do too a reminder that this
q a is live you can engage with us
directly so ask your questions say hi in
the chat hit those emojis and if you
can't just go back to the next event
website and click on the blue
join the interactive experience button
so let us jump right in but before we do
i do want to see what you like most
today
so we had a quite exciting set of
announcement and you know is it for you
let's go bigger query is it big spark it
up is it post press for all on spanner
or is it show me the earth engine
so while we wait for those results tell
me garrett you know what are you most
excited about i'm really excited about
two things openness and simplicity all
of our announcements were made to make
data more accessible more simple to use
from postgres for spanner from cross
cloud analytics with omni from
serverless spark from lucarentablow
everything is in the spirit of making
data simple to work with with and
creating an open ecosystem around gcp
for working with data that's right and
being open and simple is really what
it's all about and it's what we saw from
the demo as well uh just a reminder that
our friends from the live demo are
sticking around to help answer the
questions so you might see their faces
throughout the show
and looks like we've got some of the
poll results
it's it's all about bigquery look at
those hearts come in so this is really
good
[Laughter]
all right so let's get into our first
question it's from tiana
she asks about the availability of earth
engine we saw the great demo earlier
from the team
[Music]
how can folks get their hands on this
how can they access it and another
follow-up question which is how does it
work with bigquery gis
awesome hey tiana awesome question so
first of all google earth engine is now
in preview which means that you can go
to google.com earth engine preview and
register and we will be reaching out to
you to set you up with an account
the second key piece of what you have
seen earlier is that a in earthvention
you have a data lake of satellite
imagery and you get the means to do
geospatial analysis on imagery data and
that results they can be brought into
bigquery to match them up with all of
the data you have residing there or
using bigquery ml for instance as we
have seen so all in all awesome package
a lot of data and a great integration
directly back into bigquery i love this
and it's really what only google can
provide with the best of earth's data
and the best of our analytics solution
this is a great solution that's exactly
right
so another question comes in from chris
um multi-cloud look this is an exciting
area uh we just released bigquery omni
as a general availability that's
exciting what is google's plans around
data management does it have plans
garrett to expand our multi-cloud
approach to other data management
services
great question chris and i think it all
starts from recognizing a basic fact for
the majority of companies multi-cloud is
a reality and when we talk about data
silos we have to recognize that a modern
data silo is a multi-cloud data silo and
with big query omni we wanted to bring
simplicity to multi-cloud which means
that you can do cross-cloud analytics
and we are constantly evaluating which
of our data services makes sense in an
omni delivery and basically following
where our customer scenarios where you
are taking us to and you can expect much
more to come in that direction this is
great and it's great to see us really go
forward with multi-cloud as more and
more companies are using that as their
norm i think it's 90 of the companies
that we've surveyed actually say that
multi-cloud for them is the reality they
are living in today so let's blaze
through that complexity and deliver
multi-cloud cross-cloud analytics okay
good good uh thank you garrett uh next
question comes in from anand at cvs
health he asks this question to leah
actually so leah is there any map that
reveals all the services i think you
might have shown this at the tail end of
the demo but maybe you could go back
and do sort of a overview about the
visualizations the capabilities of
liquor
how does looker and big quarry play a
role with the visualizations for for
that uh map of earth engine
awesome yeah thanks dean so basically i
think what this question is asking is if
you can visualize the actual semantic
model that you're creating in looker to
connect all your different data assets
and actually earlier this year looker
launched the look ml diagram which is
available in looker's marketplace so you
can directly in look or create a
visualization of your data model whether
your data is in bigquery spanner or
other places that are connected to
looker so check it out that's awesome
thank you leah
the next question comes in around our
cloud sql and cloud spanner capabilities
we offer both capabilities today as you
know garrett
which one is for which purpose could you
talk a little bit about how spanner is
our fully managed database service
what is your recommendation what use
cases to use cloud sql uh as well as
cloud spanner that is a great question
because both of them are actually pretty
awesome services cloud sql is really a
managed service where you can decide
whether you want postgres or mysql and
it's really for those customers who want
to leverage basically perfect
compatibility with the postgres or the
mic sql ecosystem use all of the
packages use everything which is around
you know that that type of system and
it's a really highly reliable high
performance managed service that we are
providing spanner sits on the other end
of the spectrum if you like like it's a
cloud native database it combines
a unique set of abilities it has five
lines of availability that is unheard of
it has global consistency it's
horizontally scaling all of the things
that you want to use when you're
building massively scaling global
applications and so if you're looking on
that spectrum where it's really about
scale and yet having strong consistency
dance banner is the way to go and the
good news is you know from today's
announcement that you can use banner
with a postgres interface which means
that you don't need to relearn or take
another tool set chain in order to work
with it you can basically seamlessly
apply your postgres skills and go cloud
native with google cloud spanner
that's awesome uh let me ask another
question it's about our recent
partnership with uh tableau uh this is a
pretty exciting partnership uh we've uh
done a lot with them and could you talk
a little bit about the neat how this
strategy and this partnership helps our
looker customers specifically it is
really about simplicity and openness
this announcement means that if you are
a top low customer you will be able to
use lookers semantic models built and
look ml for trusted data access for data
governance for high performance database
access
if you are a looker customer it means
that you can add a blow self service
data visualization
right onto your local scenario so the
bottom line is is that it makes working
with data more simple it helps our
customers who are trying to find the
right balance between self-service and
flexibility and strong governance and
semantics it really brings together the
best out of two worlds no it's great and
i think it's really a reflection of our
open strategy for the data cloud again
it brings more community more customers
more use cases more capabilities that we
can bring as part of one ecosystem
that's exactly right that's awesome
um the next question comes in from uh
andrew it's a specific another question
to actually nikita about the live demo
we showed an integration of vertex ai
how does this work with bigquery ml or
bigquery machine learning nikita could
you take that question absolutely that's
a great question so for those of you who
don't know what bigquery ml is it
basically allows you to build and train
machine learning models with just a few
lines of sql so in the demo we showed
how you can use vertex ai workbench to
have access to essentially the bigquery
console but from a notebook interface
which i'm super excited about so you
could actually create and train your ml
models and sql and do all of this from
the notebook interface but still have
that connection to bigquery and be able
to use whatever tabular data you have
stored in your bigquery
okay that's awesome thank you nikita
um next question comes in from jeff
another question on looker could you
talk a little bit about how the looker
is enabling these new sets of api driven
experiences specifically jeff's asking
what are the considerations that we
should have in place for the way we
integrate it with other tools that we
should be using could you talk a little
bit about how
we can now connect with sheets
so there's some new things that we
connect with with liquor hey jeff
awesome question and i do want to
pre-text it with the following statement
looker is going to be a key element of
any data landscape basically what looker
is doing it's giving you two amazing
things one is it gives you a modeled
semantic layer basically where you can
describe your data landscape with very
rich annotations and this semantic layer
is connected directly to the database
system for instance when it runs on
bigquery it completely delegates all of
the queries right into bigquery so it
delivers stellar performance and looker
as a whole has a pretty amazing api
first concept which means that it is so
beyond bi it allows you to build data
rich applications it allows you to
basically renovate your customer
experience
your websites your internal applications
and make them really data rich and last
but not least you know we kind of gave
it away here we are also integrating
more and more products with local
semantic model for instance we are
adding connected sheets as a way how you
can analyze and discover data described
and look ml so check it out it's going
to make a big difference in your
landscape as well this is great
we are almost out of time so we're just
going to take one more question before
wrapping things up
the last question is from gerard he
talks about how at usda the many of the
methods are using different
visualizations so whether it's to blow
or esri
how does this com complement
our strategy with how we're connecting
all this data it's over 50 petabytes of
data
how do we connect all that data with
earth engine
and enable all these different ways to
process it with these different tools
absolutely hey sarad great question so
first of all it starts with making sure
that there is data and with earth engine
you get this amazing data lake of
satellite imagery and gis data
available to you the second piece is
that you need to have a powerful
processing framework and by the
integration to bigquery you can use the
most
scaling the fastest warehousing system
on this planet to analyze this data
alongside with all of the rest of your
data of your business data and last but
not least like you said it's about
complete openness the announcements that
we have shared today with look ml
allows you that you can connect top low
connect the sheets local visualizations
all on top of that right to it and make
sure that you are using the
visualizations tool that you like the
most but before we close it off because
i think we are out of time dane and i
have a very important message for all of
you and here it goes
right here
uh thanks to garrett as well as our
friends over on the demo set for
answering some great questions and
it's really been awesome hearing from
all of you i'll be sure to hop back over
to the next website javier zotero will
share all the great things happening
with google workspace thanks so much for
joining us
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to google cloud
next
all right we've had a lot of great
content so far and i have to say i
learned a lot just now watching the data
cloud session i hope you're ready for
even more i'm javier soltero vice
president and general manager for google
workspace and i'm super excited to be
with you today though to be honest i
really was hoping we could all be in
person by now
since flexibility is one of the key
themes for today we'll embrace what we
have to work with even if we can't be
together
although the last 18 months have been
filled with uncertainty we continue to
be inspired by customers and users who
found new ways to create and stay
connected
driving innovation and embracing change
are always challenges for every business
whether you're 10 people or 100 000 the
goal seems simple empower your teams to
work effectively together in part by
ensuring that your technology is an
enabler not a blocker
as we've evolved google workspace we've
been focused on helping individuals
teams and entire organizations drive
innovation and greater impact with the
tools they use every day and flexibility
has been foundational to our approach
it's why we decided to not only be cloud
first but cloud only it's why we've
always prioritized user choice it's why
we take a zero trust approach to
security and why we make sure any
product innovation we introduce is truly
built for everyone
and those principles are core to why our
customers choose us
millions of companies schools government
agencies and other organizations rely on
google workspace to help them navigate
whatever challenges they may face
they're also a big contributor to our
own continued success as a business
google has run on what is now google
workspace for the last 15 plus years and
it's part of why we have been able to
continue to innovate and adapt as we've
scaled
in that time we've grown to over 144 000
employees made 213 acquisitions added
dozens of offices around the world and
more than quadrupled the number of
annual searches we support
we've weathered changing market
conditions and user preferences and
competitive challenges just like any
business just like your business one
constant for us has always been our
tools which were designed to meet ever
shifting needs and circumstances
today we'll walk through some of the
most impactful innovations in our tool
set that help unlock the full potential
of individuals teams and organizations
in a flexible more effective hybrid
workplace
first let's talk about collaboration
effective team collaboration powers
creativity and innovation it's how
people work towards shared goals build
team culture and are able to achieve
substantially more than they would on
their own
with everyone's time in such high demand
and the explosion of collaboration tools
giving us no shortage of ways to reach
one another and work together
collaboration can often feel fragmented
conversations and workflows scattered
across disparate channels
now more than ever the technology you
choose should work intelligently and
effectively across every medium to
enable collaboration wherever it happens
last month we introduced spaces the
central place for flexible team
collaboration in google workspace
spaces are built to be tightly
integrated with calendar drive docs
sheets slides meet and tasks to provide
a uniquely better way for people to
engage in topic-based discussions share
knowledge and ideas connect across
organizational boundaries and build team
culture
all in the service of moving projects
forward
in the same way that a group of people
can accomplish more by working together
our integrated experience is greater
than the sum of its parts
helping people better collaborate and
manage their time and attention
by thoughtfully bringing together
collaboration surfaces and channels the
goal is to help people stop thinking
about where and focus instead on the
what
to continue investing in this area we've
been working with customers to
understand their needs especially the
changing circumstances
we've all been facing
in line with feedback we've gotten we'll
be adding inline topic threading more
powerful search robust security and
admin tools for content moderation and
discoverable spaces we hope this makes
it even easier for organizations and
teams to both proactively share and find
the knowledge they need to deliver
greater impact those of us working
remotely realized early on how crucial
it is to cultivate a sense of human
connection with our colleagues
no matter where or how we work we all
need to be seen heard and understood
towards that end in the last 18 months
we've invested heavily in bringing
functionality to google meat that makes
connecting virtually almost as natural
and rewarding as connecting in person
this includes ai-powered noise
cancellation low light mode and live
translated captions along with a new
intuitive user interface complete with
polls q a and breakout rooms that help
make meetings more productive inclusive
and immersive
with all of these improvements we're
seeing customers who previously opted to
use third party meeting solutions
reconsider moving to google me
we've also invested in making our tools
reflect the new ways people are working
to support hybrid and distributed teams
we've added the ability to set working
hours work location and recurring
out-of-office notifications from
calendar
we also introduced the ability to rsvp
to a meeting with a virtual or in-person
location
all these investments are geared toward
helping people better manage their time
and ultimately protect their well-being
has been a central focus for us at
google over the past year and for
countless organizations supporting their
employees during this long period of
remote work
two clear bright spots we've seen in
pivoting the remote work have been one
an increase in empathy for our
co-workers lives outside the office and
two an increased focus in collaboration
equity or the ability for everyone to
participate equally and fully
for more than a year we've all been
reduced to digital video tiles and it's
had a democratizing effect on meetings
we thought a lot about how we can
sustain this equity as more of us move
into a hybrid model
next month we're launching companion
mode which offers a unified experience
for people in the office and their
remote colleagues
those in the office can still use the
best of in-room audio and video from
google made hardware
but they can also join the meeting using
companion mode on their laptop this lets
them fully participate in the meeting
with access to chat white boarding q a
and polls along with the ability to
share content just as they would from
home
we think it's imperative to provide one
unified meeting experience regardless of
where and how people connect
and as more people head back into shared
physical spaces we're enhancing our
meetings hardware to give organizations
greater choice and flexibility
we have two new all-in-one video
conferencing devices the google meet
series 1 desk 27 and board 65
with new standards of audio video and
whiteboarding capabilities built in
these devices can turn any room or
shared space into a collaboration hub
we also have new third-party devices
coming to the google meat ecosystem
including this logitech rally bar and
this new raise rally pro speaker dock
that will automatically launch google me
for video meetings and provide an
improved audio experience from a mobile
device lastly we're partnering with
cisco to bring interoperability between
our video conferencing devices so you'll
be able to launch a google meet meeting
on webex devices and webex meetings on
google meet hardware
this sort of partnership is crucial in
delivering on our vision of google
workspace for everyone
last year our focus
was on introducing an integrated
experience across our first party
products this year we're prioritizing
strengthening the platform that supports
and extends them
this is so important because our success
is measured not only by how people use
and love our products but by the
ecosystem that thrives around them
and what we're seeing in the numbers
here is remarkable
google workspace has more than 3 billion
users and a stunning 4.8 billion apps
have been installed in google workspace
to date there are more than 5 300 public
apps available in the google workspace
marketplace
plus thousands more private apps that
customers have built for themselves
it really shows what's possible when you
combine great ideas easy to use apis and
the ability to reach a user base that's
three billion strong
while users and developers have been
able to build on apps like gmail drive
and docs for years we're now in the
process of making it just as easy to
integrate with chat spaces and meet
if google workspace is how it's done
then the google workspace platform is
how it's integrated
miro has already announced their plans
for integrating in google me
and today we're pleased to announce a
new integration for chat and spaces from
atlassian
joining me now to share more please
welcome atlassian's chief product
officer joff redfearn
hey joff great to have you with us
thanks for having me i'm delighted to be
here you know for those that aren't
familiar with atlassian can you tell us
a little bit more about it
absolutely and atlassian our mission is
to unleash the potential of every team
our team collaboration and productivity
software helps teams organize discuss
and complete shared work
but at the same time we believe there is
no one tool to solve all of the
complexity of teamwork and collaboration
every team is unique each team has its
own snowflake and they should be able to
use the best tools for the job
we focus on building the best in class
collaboration solutions and then deeply
integrating it with all the other tools
that teams need to get things done you
know it's so true that the nature of
every role and team within an
organization and the challenges they
face are unique can you tell us a little
bit more about the opportunity that
atlassian sees in building for google
workspace and how you got started yeah
today atlassian solutions already extend
and connect with thousands of tools from
collaboration
chat security devops and a whole lot
more
and we're excited to continue to extend
our partnership with google workspace to
deliver for our joint customers
work is everywhere people's chat and
inboxes it's all flooded with work and
to help turn that clutter into progress
we believe in integrating trello and
jira and our other tools everywhere work
is
the better together integration helps
atlassian and google customers
make workflow across their organization
rich content and easy actions help move
work forward in fact we are workspace
customers and this is what led us to
dream up our initial integrations
one of our first launches together was
the trello integration in gmail and that
was back in 2017.
today more than seven million people
have installed it which is really
impressive that's awesome
today we're so excited to announce the
new jira bot that connects to google
chat and to spaces and enables users to
create issues monitor them
all within the space that you're already
using for collaboration well workspace
is unique and it offers such a
significant opportunity to reach over 3
billion users
and today atlassian and google have
invested in a number of workspace
products to help users work better
together whether that's unfurling google
drive links across atlassian products
embedding an important google doc in
jira work management or creating new
trello cards from gmail but there's more
and we'll continue to listen to our
customers and then follow their needs
it's great to see the power of jira
built into chat and to spaces it's such
a powerful example of how developers can
build new experiences from across the
platform from gmail to chat to spaces to
drive
thanks joff really excited to have you
here with us and i'm very excited to
continue to develop our partnership
thanks javier have a great show
as we work with atlassian and all our
partners to build and deliver new
experiences rest assured that every one
of them is designed with security in
mind
starting with a zero trust approach to
identity in google workspace
we also employ a rigorous vetting
process to ensure partner apps are
secure before becoming available in the
google workspace marketplace
finally we recognize that it's not
always developers but the person closest
to the problem who best understands how
to make work more efficient and
impactful
to better empower these users we're
providing them access to custom no code
app sheet apps right from gmail with
dynamic email
this lets users interact the data
directly and securely from their inbox
to get things done in powerful new ways
this new experience is available today
and you'll see it in action in the
upcoming demo in a few minutes
now we talked about the powerful new
experiences in google workspace and the
platform that surrounds it but neither
of those
can transform the way your organization
works without a broader foundation for
security
we've seen too many headlines lately
about data and security breaches and
it's a powerful reminder that modern
collaboration requires modern security
legacy collaboration tools were built
for a bygone era and these headlines
make it clear that a band-aid approach
to the security problem with legacy
tools just doesn't cut it
we built google workspace with modern
collaboration and security in mind to
keep your people and your data safe
let's talk about what makes google's
approach unique
first because we're cloud only we don't
have the same vulnerabilities that
legacy collaboration tools and
infrastructure have
with google workspace there's no need
for thick client applications email
attachments or on-prem identity
directories
each of which provide bad actors with
too many opportunities for attack
and all our security protections are
included with google workspace which
means you don't need to spend money on
security add-ons and you're less
susceptible to supply chain attacks
second our entire platform is built on
the beyond corp security model which is
google's unique approach to xero trust
this lets employees work securely from
anywhere on any device without the need
for a clunky vpn
finally we're best in class at
automatically detecting and preventing
attacks from phishing to malware to
supply chain to ransomware every day we
block 15 billion spam messages 100
million phishing attempts and 3 million
deceitful urls from reaching our
customers all of this comes together to
provide google workspace customers with
the most trusted way to connect create
and collaborate
all right
now how are we working to enhance that
security vision even further well i'm
excited to announce some new
capabilities that build on this unique
approach to security
first
we've already made client-side
encryption available in beta for drive
docs sheets and slides and now we're
bringing it to google meat as well
client-side encryption gives our
customers complete control over the
privacy and confidentiality of their
data
next we're introducing data loss
prevention for chat
you can think of this as part of our
promise to enable collaboration without
compromise when it comes to security
with data loss prevention and chat you
can support spontaneous conversation
while preventing sensitive and
confidential information from leaking
outside of your organization
admins can control what users share
inside and outside their domain on
google chat and they're alerted about
any violations
finally i'm excited to share the drive
labels is now generally available this
gives organizations the ability to
classify files stored in drive based on
their sensitivity level
labels also integrates with google vault
and google workspace data loss
prevention to prevent external sharing
downloading and printing of sensitive
files
just another example of how google
workspace enables collaboration while
providing the right controls to manage
access and protect data
so we've talked you through a lot today
and the common thread is that we're
continuing to build a modern
productivity solution
one that seamlessly brings together the
right tools in the right way to help you
more effectively collaborate that
supports hybrid and distributed work and
that lets you extend and customize
solutions for your organization
and of course
one that's secure by design
it's a platform that helps you unlock
the full potential within your
organization so that you can innovate
even thrive amid the disruptions of
today and tomorrow
there will always be certain things that
are out of our control but with the
right people and tools in place as we've
seen firsthand with our customers we can
always be prepared to effectively adapt
no matter what comes next
though in this case it just so happens
that i actually know what's coming next
and it's our demo with erica troutman
director of product management for
google workspace
stay tuned to see what we just talked
about come to life
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone i'm erica troutman
product director for google workspace
there has been a ton of innovation in
workspace this past year and in the next
15 minutes i get to share with you all
the progress we've made helping teams of
all sizes to connect create and
collaborate
this demo has two parts in the first
i'll be showing you workspace in action
through a little story that we've
created and then i'll hand it off to my
colleague matt izat who will show you
all the ways developers can build on the
workspace platform
and as a reminder before we get started
this is truly a live session so you
never know what's going to happen
if you haven't already click the button
that says join the interactive
experience on the next website and then
we'll see you in the live room where you
can interact with chats and do fun stuff
like take polls which we're going to try
out right now
how many employees have you
or your company onboarded virtually this
year let us know in the poll below below
under 10
11 to 25 26 to 50 or more than 50.
i know that for me
recruiting and getting people in the
door that got harder during the start of
the pandemic taking that brand new
person that you worked so hard to find
bringing them up to speed making them
feel like they're part of the team and
really enabling them to do great work
those critical first few weeks on the
job
and of course it is so overwhelming to
be that new hire you're learning not
just the role but the tools the
processes the people
and the culture
maybe remotely
so i want to show you how workspace is
making this easier
please meet our hero pablo he's in
exactly this position he's about to
receive an offer letter from his dream
employer symbol manufacturing which by
the way is not a real company in case
you were wondering so don't go look it
up
his hiring manager allison is going to
help onboard him at the company
alison is really really excited to get
pablo on board and there are a ton of
steps in the process that she's going to
help him through
so we'll show you how she uses workspace
to help streamline that experience for
both of them even when it requires using
third party software or
custom tools the symbol team built
within workspace
the point here as javier mentioned is
that workspace is a platform that brings
together the right tools in the right
way at the right time whether those
tools are built by google or someone
else okay before we get back to pablo's
and allison's story let's see what you
have been experiencing here in the poll
wow it looks like
48 of you say that you've onboarded more
than 50 people this year that is a lot
so i think you are going to be able to
relate to allison
when you were recruiting and onboarding
what was the first thing that you did i
think uh probably you sent them an offer
letter and fingers crossed hope they
signed it
allison uses the docusign integration in
google docs to do just that so
here you see
pablo is going to check his personal
gmail
on his mobile phone
and oh he just scrolled past it there's
an offer letter in there
he's going to click on that and open up
docusign right there within the email he
clicks sees the nice cover letter alison
has sent him clicks to open the document
itself
okay great start date's right they
spelled his name right salaries what
they talked about
i think he's gonna accept
he signs the offer letter with his
finger right there on his phone without
leaving gmail come on pablo sign
sign and he signs and clicks submit and
alison
oh she's so relieved
in other systems pablo might have had to
stop what he was doing open another tab
to review and sign the agreement go back
to gmail hopefully remember where he
left off
it's just unnecessarily disruptive if
you're signing a single contract but if
you're someone who reviews and signs
contracts all the time
it's incredibly onerous so deep
integrations with leading third party
apps like docusign save you valuable
time and keep you focused on your core
job
audience if you have any favorite google
workspace integrations we would love it
if you would share those in the comments
because it's a great way to help
everyone who's out there discover
everyone who's there discover the best
of what's out there
all right back at symbol when pablo
returned his offer letter that kicked
off the onboarding process so let's see
what happens next
pablo's now at home on his personal
gmail and he sees an email from allison
come in at the top there he opens it
notices hmm this is not a typical email
this is an app sheet dynamic email which
allows him to interact with the form
without ever leaving his inbox so what
he's doing here is selecting his laptop
accessory type desk type t-shirt size
really important he enters his address
click submit and just like that symbol
can now send him his stuff this is
especially important because pablo is
going to work remotely initially
just like with the docusign example the
dynamic email lets him complete his
tasks where he is in gmail saving him
the time and hassle of toggling back and
forth between tabs and apps just to fill
out a form
and by the way if throughout any of this
you have questions regarding dynamic
emails or app sheet please comment below
so that we can address them in the q a
fast forward to pablo's first day on the
job he's received his equipment he's
excited to work he's in calendar notices
oh he's got a one-on-one with allison
coming up he's going to click on that
calendar invite
and join the meeting
with allison
allison welcomes him to symbol offers to
give him a short overview of calendar
and meet so here she's showing him how
to set up his working location and
working hours so that his colleagues who
are global know when he's available and
when he's off
features like these only available in
google workspace really improve employee
well-being and overall job satisfaction
they help employees better coordinate
how and when to work together ensuring
both productivity
and time to recharge even though our
offices might be in our bedrooms or our
kitchens
honestly pablo is going to spend a lot
of time in meetings so alison shows him
all the great new features that have
been added to meet over the past year
the interface is new and easier to use
here she's showing him how to get into
some of the advanced features he's
definitely going to want to turn on
noise cancellation which is great for
filtering out dogs barking or
neighborhood construction
and if you're having trouble hearing
someone you can just click on the closed
caption button to follow along in live
captions
even in a different language than what's
being spoken which
blows my mind ai powered translated
captions and meetings are launching soon
and only google workspace offers this
built-in for everyone
there's also a host of new features
which she's showing him here to boost
engagement so
chat polls these magical little breakout
rooms that she's going to show that
transport you to smaller groups where
you can brainstorm
whiteboards integrations with google
docs
at this point at this point the
one-on-one wraps up and alison suggests
he goes into gmail and start exploring
the spaces he's been added to
we recently launched spaces which are
the evolution of rooms in google chat
and they're the central place for team
collaboration in google workspace
pablo looks at the team space and notice
his team has written him a bunch of
welcome messages which is really great
he responds and now he's going to browse
the spaces that are available to him and
he discovers one particularly relevant
to his work quality inspector managers
north america awesome that's him
in this space he can connect with his
colleagues discuss ideas and collaborate
on projects easily
spaces are unique in that they're
tightly integrated with the entire
google workspace product set so calendar
drive docs sheets and slides meet and
tasks bringing all the tools you need to
engage in topic-based discussions share
knowledge and ideas move projects
forward and build communities and team
culture pablo notices there's a little
bubble with allison's image which means
she sent him a direct message turns out
this is pablo's first project and
allison shared a document with him which
we can see in the preview here
pablo opens the document and notices his
co-workers already pre-populated some of
the core information so
facilities number of workers per
facility on the floor and types of tasks
that they perform
pablo's job is to optimize the process
that managers use to create tickets and
send them to their quality inspectors on
the front line
okay to do this at his prior company
pablo would have needed to secure
i.t assistance at a minimum
and more probably a contractor and
probably a budget to go build an app so
not fast not easy instead pablo is going
to use app sheet he connects his sheet
to app sheet and after about an hour of
customization he's created a quality
inspection app that his team can use so
he opens it up
to file his first ticket to one of his
quality inspectors
now what
all right over on the manufacturing
floor we meet ado a quality inspector
reporting to pablo and he's just
received a pop-up notification on his
phone with the inspection ticket pablo
assigned to him so he pulls up the app
sheet app that pablo created and
performs the inspection
he's going to take a picture
of the completed job let's get let's see
if he get we can get him over there into
the app sheet app
oh he's really
noticed that he's got it uh yeah there
we go all right he's now in the app
and he's going to take a picture of the
job once it's completed he's going to
annotate that
and
submit it as closed and that then will
notify pablo on pablo's side of the app
so hopefully you saw how easy that was
to make collaboration more efficient
between an office and frontline worker
he used a really simple but powerful app
sheet app to eliminate the whole back
and forth between emails and chats and
then maybe switching to an external
ticketing system and then more emails
and more app
more chatting
at this point
if any of you can think of useful
patients for app sheet in your
organization please share those with us
in the form below so think about
all of those repetitive tasks that make
you crazy day to day those are the kind
of things that app sheet can automate
for you
all right back to pablo let's see if
we're
okay
um still on app sheet here for just a
quick second we're going to get back to
pablo's day-to-day in his first week on
the job any moment here
let's see
i'm looking here you guys have some
really interesting um
oh scrolling through here asana people
like the asana integration i saw people
use hello sign that stuff is all
fantastic
all right can we are we back to pablo
we're back to pablo
back to paolo it's the end of his first
week on the job he pulls up calendar in
the sidebar while in gmail and he
notices he should be joining the team
meeting so he clicks to join
on the call allison introduces pablo to
everyone and asks him to share his
reflections on his first week and he's
really proud of the app that he built an
app sheet especially since this is a
tool the entire team can adopt he shows
how easy it is to create requests assign
one to an inspector follow the status he
also pulls up the request that he sent
to ado that was already completed
and if pablo were joining from a
conference room because hopefully
someday he will he could use companion
mode a feature that's only available in
google meet to seamlessly join and share
from his laptop while using in-room
audio and video
and with some congratulatory emojis from
his colleagues alison closes off the
meeting and the weekend can begin
i think it's fair to say that pablo
helped us with quite a lot of demos in
his first week on the job so thank you
pablo
and i hope that you can see how at every
turn google workspace helped people
connect and collaborate to get more done
with an intuitive and integrated set of
tools
with that i'd like to introduce my
colleague matt isaat who's going to take
us under the hood and talk about how you
can build on the workspace platform
thanks erica hi everyone
i'm matthew izat and i lead product for
the google workspace platform
under that hood is a powerful engine
let's talk about how you can take
advantage and build on the workspace
platform
as javier mentioned more than 4.8
billion apps have been installed in
workspace to date
this stunning number illustrates that
workspace is more than a hub for work
it's a powerful enabler of workflows
the opportunity to build on the
workspace platform is massive nearly
half the world's population is already
using workspace
that's a huge audience whether you want
to grow an existing business app or
build an entirely new business on the
platform
to help you build experiences to reach
these three billion users
we've delivered a range of tools so you
can innovate
from no code options like appsheet as
erica discovered to powerful scripting
with apps script to a complete set of
easy to use
apis and we've been listening to your
feedback
developers want to use their own
preferred language and tools when
building integrations like workspace
add-ons or chat apps or even using our
large collection of rest apis
so we've opened up the platform to
support development with any tools
any language on any public cloud
of course if you're using google cloud
and why wouldn't you take advantage of
cloud run
cloud data store and cloud ai to power
your app
so there's a big opportunity to build on
the workspace platform
with the tools and languages
of your choice
now let's take a look at how the process
works across the three core stages of
app development
the design
develop
and publish phases of your app
starting with the design phase we've
created the card builder tool
this tool allows you to layout the
visual design and user experience of
your app
there are a range of templates and you
can also drag and drop components of the
app around like a no code platform
but for more advanced developers you
also have the ability to see the code in
the editor and make updates there as
well
as we move on to the develop phase you
now have a range of language and tooling
to choose from
whether using options from google like
apps script or your own preferred
language and tooling
while apps script is a great option for
developers we have invested in and
extended the google workspace platform
to embrace a wider range of industry
standard tools
so developers can use their own tech
stack and reuse their existing code when
building for workspace
when your integration is complete
congratulations you're ready to publish
it for public use in the workspace
marketplace where it will be available
for billions of users
it's worth noting that there are more
than 5
300 publicly available apps in the
marketplace today
this number really highlights the
diversity of use cases and remarkable
opportunity for developers in building
for workspace
and of course if you're developing a
custom app for use in your own
organization
you have the ability to publish that app
privately so it remains available
exclusively for the use of your
organization
so there you have it a quick tour of how
you design
develop and publish new integrations for
workspace
now let's hear from you
what workspace platform technologies are
you curious to learn more about
throughout the conference
is it developer tools and languages like
apps script or app sheet
or maybe it's product integration
through add-ons or chat apps
or perhaps data apis or data access
through workspace apis
but that's enough about the technology
platform
why don't we take a look at a few real
world examples of integrations developed
for workspace
and let's start with the copper crm
add-on for gmail
copper identified a problem
workspace users needed a simple but
powerful crm solution that is built to
work with apps and workspace so
naturally they built a solution
here you can see it in action as a sales
rep receives an email from a customer
the copper add-on detects the email
after installation the copper add-on
will detect the email and pull up the
customer information
automatically
with the customer's information right
next to their email
so when we click through the uh the
installation we'll eventually get to
seeing the
there we are they caught as you can see
the copper
the copper add-on has detected the email
and pull up the
information automatically of the user
and with the customer's information
right next to their email the sales rep
has all the insight they need from
copper and can craft the best response
to the customer
all without leaving gmail
copper is a perfect example of business
that has grown alongside workspace
and today 100
yes that's correct all of their business
comes from workspace customers
these are customers who value a
best-in-class crm solution with deep
native integration to critical workspace
apps such as gmail drive and calendar
the opportunity to build for the
workspace platform spans multiple
surface areas
so let's take a look at how this looks
in chat and spaces
with the brand new jira bot from
atlassian
here you can see a customer service rep
jumping into the customer success chat
space to report an issue with a customer
after a short discussion in the space
the rep creates an issue in jira via the
jira bot
every time there's a status update on
the case the jira bot will update the
team members in the chat
this saves the entire team valuable time
they might have spent going back and
forth to jira and checking updates
it also helps the team focus on
collaborating together to help the
customer instead of navigating their
tools
we'd love to hear what workspace
integration or apps you're using or
would like to see
please share in the comments so the
community hears what are some of the
best
these are just a few examples of how
developers are innovating in workspace
and driving business value for
themselves and their customers
we can't wait to see what you create and
innovate on workspace whether it's a no
code app or professionally developed
solution
either way we've provided a rich canvas
for you to start with and believe the
best is yet to come
so looking at the chat it looks like
you're excited to get going and ready to
get started
visit
developers.google.com workspace to learn
more about integrating with workspace
thanks to my colleague matt for taking
us under the hood with workspace today
and a special thanks to you
our audience for your engagement we love
seeing your comments on chat now stay
tuned for our live q a covering
everything from our spotlight and this
demo
thank you so much we'll see you soon
[Music]
thanks so much erica and matt it's
absolutely awesome to see all the new
experiences coming into workspace
hi everyone
welcome to the live q a i'm katie and
i'm javier so excited to see all of you
and engage with all of you today
absolutely
and before we start just a reminder this
is an absolutely live q a and that means
you can engage with us directly so
please ask questions in the chat
tell us where you're from we would love
to hear from you
and if you can't just go back to the
next event website and click on the blue
button that says join the interactive
experience and you'll be all set
so to get this going let's go ahead and
start with a poll and see who we've got
together today let's do it all right so
we want to hear what's your role at work
do you work in the i.t department
are you a developer
are you a person who uses workspace just
in the process of your daily work or
something else entirely let us know in
the chat
all right javier while we wait for those
results
why don't you answer a question for us
let's do it
tell us what are you most excited about
in workspace these days well i'm excited
about the pace at which we're delivering
some amazing new capabilities for people
but i'm most excited about the way we're
bringing the workspace products closer
together
and helping people be that much more
effective at getting their work done
collaborating with their colleagues uh
building documents basically coming
translating ideas and turning them into
reality by using our products it's very
exciting and we can't wait for all the
stuff that we're going to come out with
this year and next absolutely and i feel
like as i've seen the chats coming in
customers are talking about examples of
how they're using workspace how they're
going to use some of the new app sheet
innovation in gmail so it's really
exciting
okay our poll results have come back in
and it looks like do you want to read
the results um well it looks like we
have pretty even split between our i.t
uh folks and developers which is great
and consistent with like one of the key
there's a lot of great content for all
of you uh uh next uh and then we also
have a healthy portion of end users and
uh other folks so uh widening the
audience trying to make this uh this
highly relevant topic for a lot of
people not just technology professionals
people use this every day so i'm excited
to see this many people absolutely all
right let's jump in with our first
question let's do it it comes from lucy
who says i saw the news about the new
work safer program can you tell us a bit
more about that
sure thank you for the question lucy so
uh we're announcing work safer
as a way to bring the best of google
workspace and of google cloud security
together to help companies rise to this
growing threat
of cyber security incidents etc and so
it brings together google workspace with
some exciting innovation from our
security team and for those customers
that have broader more diverse
environments we've partnered with two of
the best names in the security business
palo alto networks and crowdstrike to
create a complete solution for these
companies to be able to uh remain secure
in a much more challenging environment
that's great that's great to hear kind
of an all-in-one solution yup
all right
let's move on to question number two uh
and this one's going to be for erica
um and it comes from michael at cepharon
who asks is it hard to collaborate if
members are using different platforms to
join
for example
he's running off of google's tool set
but has a partner who's using a
different platform
this is a really important question
michael thank you for that i think you
the reality is that we live in a world
where where there's different sets of of
products that you or your partners or
your customers are going to be using and
it's fundamental to
you know our our way of viewing the
world that that workspace should not be
a wild garden it should integrate it
should
connect and make those uh those tasks
easier for you so on the on the drive
doc sheet slides side we invest really
deeply in making uh interoperability
with microsoft in particular totally
seamless and
and very easy to to use so for example
you can open up microsoft documents in
the google editor and have the full
interactive experience those changes
will be saved back to your microsoft
document including comments all of those
changes are updated in real time but
there's also a really important third
party compatibility component which i
would love for my colleague matt to to
discuss
yeah it's fundamental to us that whether
using
tools which interoperate with the
workspace suite or
things which complement the types of
functionality that we offer that these
all work together i'll pick one example
we recently
announced uh our new partnership with uh
miro which is company that does uh
virtual whiteboarding or collaborative
canvassing uh and you can imagine that
as you're working with that tool set uh
not only are you building things on your
virtual canvas but you're scheduling
meetings uh you're holding meetings of
what you want to collaborate uh in real
time while changing things within that
tool uh and so what we are doing is
making it really easy for you to
schedule a meeting calendar join a
meeting and meet at the same time be
working in your uh miro whiteboard
so yes we believe very strongly that all
these things should work better together
that workspace and partners delivers a
really great experience for our
customers and users
that's great thank you all right our
next question comes from bam bang who's
uh with chandra osri and asks must we
have or use gmail or company email
for uh using the rest of google cloud
and workspace and i think erica this is
probably one for you um
sure yeah happy to take that we have
tailored offerings that don't require
you to migrate emails so workspace
essentials is is perfect for that it
includes the workspace uh product set
but without email so it integrates
easily and we also have deep
interoperability with uh outlook and
calendar
got it great
javier we're gonna move to you next okay
and the question comes from hannah
and hannah says that uh her team loves
new features like being able to jump
right into a meet from a dock and is
wondering will integrations like that be
extended to other apps inside workspace
yes in fact we're very excited to
continue to advance the opportunity of
bringing
you know to start actually from the
real-time collaborative experience that
google docs pioneered now actually 15
years ago i think yesterday was our 15th
birthday one more and we can drive
and
be able to
allow users to go from working
in real time with others in a document
to easily
getting into a live video feed where you
can hear and see each other
and sort of that progression i guess is
really important part of ensuring
seamless collaboration and it applies
we see to both our own editors as well
as as matt mentioned uh third parties
over time yeah got it yeah makes sense
well we're going to stay with you javier
for this next question which comes from
carter
who says my company uses a lot of point
solutions like zoom and slack in
addition to having microsoft and google
licenses
so what would you say is the argument
for consolidating
well look uh one of the strongest
aspects of google workspace is the
element of choice the choice that users
make billions of users have made to
select individual products for key roles
in their lives at work etc and so we're
guided as we refine these products by
that sense of
affinity that people have to the
approach that we bring that approach
is best expressed and and nurtured i
think through deeper and better
integration between our products to
create something that's ultimately net
new and at the same time we recognize
that there are other companies around us
in this vibrant ecosystem of ours that
offer different points of view and
different aspects of what we also
provide and we believe that there's
ample opportunity for users to make an
informed choice uh and really recognize
it comes down to familiarity uh with the
products the sense of security that you
get from an integrated solution and
ultimately the cost so
it's a choice everyone makes and over
time we feel really good about the
continued growth of our ecosystem that's
great that's great thank you
erica we're coming back to you with a
question from miles who asks how do you
plan to win over diehard fans of excel
and other microsoft creation tools
all right a good challenging question
from miles uh well
as javier said we we introduced docs and
sheets about 15 years ago and that
fundamentally rethought what a file
should be
our belief is that these experiences
need to leverage the best that the
internet has to offer so interactivity
connectivity and data and they shouldn't
just be a physical a digital
representation of a physical piece of
paper that lives on your hard drive and
that's in stark contrast to the mental
model that you know legacy solutions
have evolved from
over the years we've invested a ton in
user experience and making this
incredibly easy to adopt and um and the
great thing is that all of this ease of
use which billions of people take
advantage of is has google security you
know enmeshed and underpinning the whole
experience i would call out a couple of
features that i hope people are aware of
but if they're not they should be so
connected sheets for example if you
weren't aware allows sheets users to
analyze
billions of rows of data yes billions in
a single sheet so that really pushes the
envelope for what a productivity tool
can do and um our innovation around
smart canvas which
really supercharges interactivity
intelligence and connection to rich data
in the form of these modular building
blocks that transcend the file
boundaries so we bring in
smart chips that bring rich information
about people events files
templates we have tables and task lists
all of that really further enhances what
um what these files should be so what i
would say is for any of the micro die
hard microsoft fans we would love uh to
give you a tour and i bet we could
change your mind got it great thanks
erica
all right javier we're coming to you
next uh with a question from juliet who
comments that there have been a lot of
security breaches lately in the news
and what are we doing from a workspace
perspective to protect customers from
these sorts of attacks
well look it's a great question and uh
thank you uh uh for the question
a lot of these attacks originate from
the uh the architecture and habits that
went along with legacy products right
the sharing models the approach for
storing content the reliance on uh uh
heavy powerful clients that that store a
lot of information locally on them but
don't necessarily provide the best
degree of security
google workspace was born in a different
era and has had since the very beginning
a different point of view about the
design and the approach to security and
it comes i guess as part of us being
cloud only right like we we grew up and
we're architected for a the distributed
world in which we live in now and it is
the reason behind why our products are
so effective
so
we've continued to invest around that to
make it even clearer how along with
enhancements and innovative capabilities
from google cloud security like
beyondcorp uh uh et cetera we we
established a completely different model
for securing content while ensuring the
absolute best and most effective level
of collaboration with within a company
and beyond the company so externally
with other third parties etc and
partners
absolutely so it's really architected
for to be safe in this world yes yes and
actually look it you mentioned this idea
of habits right like these uh um
the notion of attachments right like the
model that people uh grew up with uh uh
you know when productivity tools digital
productivity were first introduced
um is the main vector through which a
lot of these ransomware and other
terrible things tend to heart start
right
somebody you know either opens an email
like a phishing attempt or a malicious
attachment something that gets spread
through you know various different tools
that people are used to using
and
companies are really desperate to say
how do we actually put a stop to this
and by the way can we do that in a way
that actually
works us
towards a
sense of transformation in our company
so it's not just about
securing your communication and
collaboration but ultimately taking that
full opportunity to make it more
effective at the same time so it's
pretty exciting yeah it is exciting and
you know you have been working in this
space for so long you mentioned the
legacy tools and you know from accompli
to you know work at different companies
you've been so focused on the
productivity market what have you
learned across those different
experiences and different products that
is
most important and the knowledge that
that you use today well listen i think
the the most honest answer that question
uh and it may surprise some of you is
you can't please everybody right um
you're building products that play these
very crucial roles in people's personal
lives at school at work and part of
their power is that they are horizontal
in nature they allow people their their
canvases for creation articulation of
ideas etc
and so you have to be
very
careful and deliberate about the process
you use to evolve those products and so
as i mentioned earlier you know we we
began our our journey as google in the
collaboration space in a very particular
point in time
where it allowed us to have a different
point of view a more modern approach
um and and an eye towards
simplicity that didn't undermine the
sophistication and power of the products
that we were doing that's what we are
really strongest at and so as a result
the task of evolving those opinions in
products like docs or sheets or gmail or
meet any one of these products
they are the representation of a point
of view that google is bringing
that customers are actually informing
and helping us refine over time
but it ultimately requires that we
really understand what it is that we
believe the right result is for our
customers and that
may mean in some cases that these
products are are uniquely powerful for
key scenarios
and are not necessarily just like
something that
uh can be used for they're not
multi-tools right
so it's a really exciting and
challenging journey for us
absolutely
and having that strong point of view
it's a great opportunity to get feedback
from all the customers who are living
listening now please share your feedback
in the chat we want to hear from you
all right we have another question it's
coming in from john and it's going to be
for matt
and john asks what are you doing to
encourage developers and isvs to build
for workspace
yeah thanks for asking the question i
know we talk a lot about
customers and users but at the heart of
a successful platform is developers
and so what makes a developer want to
build on a platform let's start with our
open philosophy
google as a company for a long time has
believed in the openness of data the
openness of access to platform and that
extends to workspace
we built an extensive
set of apis and frameworks and they are
completely open you can go build
something today right now
secondly is reach
if you are building something on a
platform you want an audience right you
want to build a business on a platform
you want to have success your customers
have success
and we have
our workspace certainly has a lot of
reach we talk about three billion users
and millions of paying
businesses and paying customers
this is fundamental for why you want to
be on the workspace platform
uh finally i mentioned apis and
frameworks we've put a lot of effort
into and we continue to put a lot of
effort into making sure they're easy to
use and easy to build on so easy as i
mean from developer point of view it
shouldn't take you months and months of
trying to deduce how something works
from poorly written documentation rather
it should be something that you could
you know build up a prototype in an
afternoon uh and we believe we've made
it that way for you uh and finally
you've seen a lot of logos on our slides
today and that's our discussion points
today
these are really proof points atlassian
mural docusign
of the success our partners are having
and the fact that we believe in being
better together
absolutely thanks matt
okay javier we're coming back to you
okay with a question from laura
hello laura yes laura's asking with
kovid still keeping a lot of companies
remote
what is google and google workspace team
doing to offset the difficulties of
distributed work
a lot is the honest simplest answer um
now look i think uh
there's a
it's a two-part answer for from one side
as an organization
uh
we we have to listen to people we have
to get feedback from employees we've
learned a lot
uh uh from each other and about the
different situations that our employees
have to face on a daily basis it's
informed our point of view as i
mentioned earlier this idea of having an
opinion we we know that
that just because work doesn't take
place in a specific named location
anymore
that there aren't like a whole host of
new problems and opportunities
that you have to address not just with
products by the way but also with
policies that a company
adopts like recovery days and a home
office stipend etc
now from a product perspective
we have this incredible opportunity to
channel those learnings along with the
input that we get from our customers
from around the world and even our users
to
say how are we helping and how can we be
more helpful i guess in in such a broad
uniform sense of the word by helping
people not just
use these products but be successful
with them um and again this involves a
whole lot of listening um which is why
i'm great to have it's you know the uh
dynamic experience here with cloud next
and also all these great conversations
with users and customers that we've been
having uh everywhere um so you know
there's it's a it's a never-ending task
absolutely two across two parts the
order and the product that's right yeah
that's right
all right well it looks like we are out
of time so
i'd like to thank everyone for joining
us today and a huge thank you to javier
erica and matt thank you katie of course
it's great to be here all together thank
you everyone online for joining in today
and i'd like to remind you that even
though we finished the live q a the day
is not over yet and there's actually
another great session that's about to
begin shortly and it's from our own
chief diversity officer melanie parker
who's going to be leading a dei
spotlight session
that talks about the importance of stem
and creating pathways to jobs in tech
it's a really important topic and i hope
you all tune in to check it out
the details are on the next website
thanks so much for joining us
bye
thanks everybody
[Music]
hello everyone
my name is melanie parker and i am
google's chief diversity officer
i'd also like to introduce molini who's
with us today she's going to be
providing asl interpretation
it is great to be back for my third
google cloud next this time for a look
at nurturing and developing pathways to
careers in tech
today i'd like to talk about how
building a more diverse inclusive
culture is not just a competitive
advantage for us at google but it's a
responsibility as well
and as we get started i want to let you
know that the chat is open so you can
engage with each other during this
session i want you to share thoughts
share where you're tuning in from and
we'll have a few of our folks on hand to
join the conversation
we'll also get into what we're doing to
widen pathways to tech careers at google
and across our industry but first i am
so proud to say that google is committed
to making diversity equity and inclusion
a part of everything we do
from how we build our products to how we
build our workforce i work hand in hand
with our ceo sunder pushai and is part
of our executive leadership team to
bring our global dei strategy to life
i also lead a passionate group of people
whose work touches over
140 000 employees stretches across
nearly 60 countries and helps millions
of users who use our products and our
platforms to run their households their
businesses and their lives
and personally i traveled down a very
unlikely path to land this position
i'm a black woman who grew up in a small
town in north carolina my brother and i
are proud alumni of hbcus
and we were the first generation in our
family to bring home a college degree
which i earned at a historically black
university hampton university
and unlike many of my peers i didn't
have anyone at home to explain the
unwritten rules of corporate america or
to help me navigate my career instead i
cobbled together a community of mentors
managers and inspirational voices who
help me find my path
and that's an idea that i want to focus
on today
access opportunity and networking are
critically important building blocks for
a successful tech career
and that's especially true for folks
like me who come from non-traditional
backgrounds
too many people from underrepresented
communities find themselves confronting
systemic inequalities such as a lack of
access to stem education or access to
high-speed internet that disrupt the
pathway to tech careers
and for many who do navigate the pathway
we've seen how the weight of inequality
can foster a sense of imposter syndrome
once on the inside
it's that sinking feeling of doubt in
our abilities and a feeling like a fraud
or that we don't belong and that for
some it will linger for an entire career
overcoming inequality and creating
access to opportunity including for our
underrepresented talent this is a top
priority at google
and we're taking decisive actions that
create opportunities and steadily grow a
workforce that reflects the world around
us to launch programs that support our
communities globally and to build
products that better serve all of our
users in other words to build for
everyone we need to weave diverse
perspectives into every step of our
design
engineering and testing processes
and innovative ideas can come from
everyone from googlers at the grassroots
level to engaged leaders and to
establish diversity councils across the
company
as an example the google meet team
worked on the light enhancement feature
to better represent all skin tones in an
inclusive way during our video calls and
through feedback from a diverse group of
testers the team was able to determine
the right algorithm that better work for
all individuals across the skin tone
spectrum
and this ensured that all video calls on
meat work well for everyone and it was
thanks to the collaborative work and
questioning how to make products
equitable for all
in another example
google has internal teams to foster
equity through technology empowering our
black plus community to innovate in the
digital space by supporting their
educational journey and helping them
land roles in the tech industry
and we've also built external programs
like cloud career jumpstart it's a 12
week learning course for
underrepresented students with computer
science or information systems related
majors or the relevant experience and it
offers free access to google cloud
associate cloud engineer training to
prepare for the certification exam
we just published our diversity annual
report and i am excited to share that
2020 was our best year yet for hiring
our black plus and latinx plus googlers
in the us
it was also our best year ever for
hiring women in tech in the us and
globally
in addition to hiring we're also
redoubling the focus on retaining
googlers from all underrepresented
groups and in full transparency this is
an area where we can and we must do
better
google depends on the best brightest and
most diverse talent to not only help us
solve today's challenges but also to
co-create solutions to tomorrow's
problems
so we are building a lasting model of
inclusion and belonging that helps all
employees feel seen
connected supported and i hope
proud to be in service
belonging is key to re-recruiting our
workforce and acknowledging that not
everyone experiences our culture the
same way
despite our best efforts some team
members are still feeling left out
there is work to do around building the
culture that we've all been working so
hard to co-create
clearly there's some other missing
element
and as different as we are we all have
the same underlying need to fill value
to feel like our contributions matter to
feel like we belong here
but being included isn't necessarily
feeling like you belong
being invited to the table is not the
same as being welcome at the table and
being valued like you belong
personally i've been inspired by the
work of john powell
john is an expert in the areas of civil
rights and civil liberties and he's a
professor at berkeley and he leads the
institute of othering and belonging and
he looks at our primal need as humans to
belong
and what fosters belonging and what
prevents it
and if you think about it one of our
primal fears is to be ostracized by a
group
aside from food and shelter we need to
belong and we've evolved to ensure that
we could maintain access to the
resources that the group has
many behaviors are dictated by this need
to be accepted by others but we're also
guided by the fear of losing that very
acceptance
and we've evolved to protect ourselves
and our loved ones by determining who's
in and who's out and that comes down to
identifying who's the least risk
those that we perceive most like us and
relegating those who aren't to the
outcrowd
and john calls that primal sorting of
people into ins and outs the cool kids
versus the non-cool kids as othering and
we don't necessarily do this consciously
but it is the behavior that stems from
our unconscious bias the subtle ways
that we send messages
even virtually of who's cool and who's
not who's valued who's not and that's
why i believe that our work it's not
truly possible until we foster this
sense of belonging and as evolved humans
we have control over this there are ways
to check in with ourselves
noticing are we turning inward focusing
on only who and what we know versus
turning outward to connect with and
explicitly work with other groups and to
seek ways to build common ground
and that would foster belonging and
empathy
and this means that we need to co-create
the workplace experience with our
internal communities and redefine what
it means to be a googler by
acknowledging where we can do better
and by ensuring everyone feels like they
belong
is positioned to do their best work and
can confidently bring their authentic
whole selves to work each day
and for underrepresented talent this can
make the difference between surviving
and thriving in their career
and for those of us who are accustomed
to muting parts of who we are
authenticity empowers us to do our very
best work
last summer at the start of the global
racial justice movement i realized that
i could no longer code switch or check
parts of myself at the door in an act of
self-preservation
to lead our deep work in racial equity
and address the systemic and structural
barriers
i needed to reconcile the most
vulnerable parts of my own identity as a
black woman with the black woman who
happens to lead diversity at google
and i know that this is the type of
workplace environment that we strive to
build and with our collective consistent
efforts that is what we'll do
we know that google is most helpful when
our products and our services reflect
the needs of the people who are using
them
to best serve our diverse global
community of users we need a more
representative workforce and while we're
making progress we know equalities
persist around access opportunity and
networking for underrepresented talent
but through investments in creating
pathways to stem and with help from
allies we can broaden the talent
pipeline improve product design and
fulfill our mission of making dei part
of everything that we do
what does this look like there's a real
cognitive shift happening both inside
and outside of google around diversity
equity and inclusion and how we can best
build for everyone
externally we're creating pathways to
careers in tech as early as elementary
and high school
we're expanding recruitment beyond the
usual campuses like stanford berkeley
harvard yale and doubling down on higher
education institutions like hispanic
serving institutions and historically
black colleges and universities serving
underrepresented talent why because we
know that 25
of black graduates with stem degrees for
example they come from hbcus just like
the one i attended
so this year we began deepening and
sustaining relationships with hbcus
in june we announced an historic
unrestricted 50 million dollar grant
that allows the presidents of these
esteemed institutions to allocate
resources in the manner that they see
fit
we're also broadening career pathways to
include a major grow with google career
readiness investment that supports our
hispanic serving institutions around the
us
a significant economic opportunity grant
for workforce development and digital
skills training to thousands of
hispanics and a career readiness program
for native american indigenous serving
institutions
and that's just the slice of the work
that we're doing externally
and while i mention that 2020 was
google's biggest year in terms of hiring
black and latinx talent in the us
we know that there's much more work to
do inside of google to retain and grow
our talent
so broadly speaking we've developed
racial equity education for all googlers
and incorporated it into our new hire
orientation
we've doubled the size of our retention
and progression team and we're on a path
to triple this team by 2022
and this enables us to provide
one-to-one support like coaching
networking and internal mobility
opportunities to help under-represented
googlers grow and thrive
and we've rolled out an innovative
onboarding program for our new black
googlers so that they feel more
supported right from the start
our employees want to know that they can
grow and thrive with us and that's one
reason why we're working to increase
leadership representation among women
black and latinx googlers
we've introduced pathways to sponsorship
for women in technical leadership roles
it's designed to accelerate their
careers
we leverage partnerships with more than
two dozen community and professional
organizations and these partners offer
professional development as well as
networking opportunities for
underrepresented googlers
we also offer skills building
initiatives like the cloud technical
residency program and with great
intention we've begun building a culture
of belonging for all googlers as i
described earlier
we've been very open about our successes
and our challenges and i invite you to
explore this further at
diversity.google.com
now i know many of you are wondering
what can i do so as you weigh your own
strategies around engagement and
retention consider the role of allies
and driving results
allies can be leaders managers and peers
they support folks in marginalized
groups to which they don't identify
internally we've created a number of
pathways for allies that are seeking to
support our underrepresented colleagues
these include an allyship pathway with
group exercises for allies and resources
for practicing or encouraging inclusive
behaviors
we also have google in residence
experience google software engineers
teach introductory computer science
classes on hbcu campuses
and we have faculty and residents we
have more than 50 faculty members from
30 hbcus to design project-based
industry-informed content and to
implement that content in their
classrooms
google has doubled in size in the past
few years we know our dei commitments
need to keep pace
operating at this global scale it
heightens our sense of responsibility
around dei and to paraphrase my
colleague annie jean baptiste there's no
blueprint to doing this work perfectly
and while we don't have all the answers
we're eager to share what we've learned
and also to learn from others and in the
spirit of learning leadership i hope
i'll be invited to share more
discoveries in progress at google cloud
next 22
in closing when our mission is to build
for everyone we have to work with
everyone
so with help from allies and through
smart investments and creating pathways
to stem careers i am confident our
talent pipeline will flourish
real meaningful change can take years we
know but there's no need to wait for
change to come
if you haven't already please head over
to the chat room and join the discussion
there you can share some of your
successes and your challenges around
creating pathways to tech careers this
kind of dialogue can open minds and
truly inspire change
i look forward to sharing more progress
with you next year and i'll bring others
along who've been on this journey with
us to share their experiences
thank you for wrapping up day one of
google cloud next with me it's been
great sharing this time with you
we look forward to seeing you all here
tomorrow for day two which kicks off
with our developer keynote
until then be sure to register at g dot
co slash cloud next for access to all of
our content and join the conversation on
social using
google cloud next see you tomorrow
[Music]
you